Ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja.
Wonka W.
am NASA
und
erайde
können
Genau
Ja
Heute basteln wir mal wieder ein bisschen was
Was was ich schon eine Weile machen will
Zumindest anfangen
Hätte ich schon gar nicht
Bezweifelt sogar, dass wir irgendwas raus bekommen
Heute war es schon ganz annehmbar
Funktioniert
Ich muss mal Updates machen in der VM
Wenn wir gerade dabei sind
Was?
Keine Updates?
Es erscheint mir ein bisschen unrealistisch, dass es keine Updates gibt
Ich hatte die VM in ein paar Wochen nicht mehr an
Es gibt keine Updates?
Das ist sehr merkwürdig
In irgendwelchen Gründen habe ich da einen Snapshot gemacht
Der ist eigentlich komplett überflüssig
Dankeschön für die ganzen Subs Leute
Ihr Selfmade Iced Mr. Amec
Foggers
Warum gibt es keine Updates?
Habe ich vorhin schon mal Updates?
Da muss es Updates geben
Okay wir kriegen das ganz einfach raus
Ob ich die aktuellsten Updates drauf habe
Oder ob Pacman irgendwie komisches Zeug macht
Weil
Machen wir hier mal zu
Machen wir mal Chrome auf
Gucken wir mal was es für eine Chrome Version ist
108, das ist nicht das aktuelle
Von wann ist das?
Von wann ist das Bild?
Ja, es ist der 1412
Da gab es auf jeden Fall
Ich Reboote mal
Ich Reboote mal, man weiß ja nie
Komm her, keine Ahnung
Hodei, Dankeschön für den Sub
Rebooten, Rebooten schadet ja nichts
Bekanntlichermaßen
Warum ist denn da oben diese Kackleiste?
Ich weiß es nicht
Und was sehe ich da im Hintergrund?
Nothing to do?
Das kann nicht sein
Ich mache die vor allem gerade nochmal auf der anderen Kiste an
Dass es da keine Updates für gibt
Da ist Sass, äußerst
Sass
Das kann man auf der anderen Seite nicht aufmachen
Hyper Sass
So, wir können uns mal ausloggen
Was haben wir hier drinnen denn immer?
Ein ordentliches Dark Theme und alles
Warum hat er keine Updates?
Das kann auch das da stimmen sein
Packman, Reset
Updates, irgendwie sowas
Man konnte doch dem Ding sagen
oder irgendwie Force
Force Update oder
Da hat er auch manchmal so ein Problem gehabt, dass es hing
Packman, Don't Detect
Updates
Ja
Muss man bestimmt irgendwas lösen
Update your Mirrors, ok alles klar, das machen wir
Wir updaten die Mirrors
Packman, Package List
Ja gut, das mache ich ja hier oben schon
Da stimmt irgendwas, net
Hier geht das Packman, Mirrors
oder sowas
Macht man das nochmal
Server, was habe ich denn hier
Packman
Pack Mirrors
Oder wie ist das?
Mirrors hier
Sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr merkwürdig
Auch wenn ich die Coolbox aufmache
habe ich doch bestimmt Updates hier
Ja, guck hier, hier sind Updates
Also aus irgendwelchen Gründen ist mein Dinox der Meinung, es gibt keine Updates
Das müssen wir erstmal fixen
Bevor es
Bei Packman
Mirror List
Wahrscheinlich muss ich
Packman, Mirrors, wie hat man den
Rahmen geupdatet?
Das weiß ich aus dem Kopf net
Eigentlich wollen wir was programmieren
Das Problem ist, ich stelle gerade fest, dass meine VM sich nicht mehr
updatet
Ich bin mir nicht ganz sicher, warum
Packman, Update,
Mirrors
Da gab es doch so einen
Es ist Packman, Mirrors
Was macht denn
Minus Minus Fast Track
Ne, ne, ne, das will ich net
Ich will
Ich will bei Speed
Oder irgendwie sowas, gibt es doch
Minus F5 macht was?
Ok
Packman, Mirrors
Minus F5
Ok
Ah, siehste
Schon
Aber das erscheint mir trotzdem
ein bisschen wenig
Oder?
Aber okay, ich meine vielleicht
Es ist auch nur der Chrome, es kann ja
durchaus sein
Der andere Grämpel
funktioniert ja
Ja, lass wir mal updaten, okay, kein Schimmer, warum das eben nicht funktioniert hat, aber
alles in Ordnung, wenigstens das geht.
So, dann lassen wir jetzt nämlich gerade mal updaten, bevor wir anfangen, ich hab nämlich
die VM umgezogen, dass wir jetzt wieder hier im Stream was machen können, update, checken
wir hier ob es Updates gibt, update all, und dann muss ich einstellen, dass man in der
VM, wo stellte man das nochmal ein, man konnte das irgendwo in der VM einstellen, dass bei
Display, dass der diese Leiste ausblendet.
Ja, du hattest nur ein Chrome-Update, aber du hattest deine VM ja auch öfters an als
vor einem Monat oder so, das ist ja die alte VM, die hab ich umgezogen gerade von der anderen
VM.
Was auch immer, okay, wo konnte man das jetzt in VM noch mal einstellen, was war das denn,
das ist immer, VM ist teilweise von der Konfig her echt abartig, also was ich einstellen
will ist, dass hier oben diese Leiste, dass man die Leiste gar nicht mehr sieht, man sieht
die Leiste immer nur noch so ein Stück, vermute mal das war irgendwo hier und dann advanced,
ne, wo könnte sich das, wo könnte sich das verstecken, wo immer Tools, ich google einfach
jetzt, Views, Viewtools Toolbar, ne, oder meinste hier, vielleicht auch hier für alles, vielleicht
auch hier für alles Display, hier, schau Edge, wenn anpinnt, jetzt ist weg, das ist ja wirklich
wieder kaum was zu finden gewesen, ja, okay nice, also das haben wir, abgedatet haben
wir, wir können mal ein Kernel-Update machen, wenn wir gerade schon dabei sind, das Ding
mal zu update, naja, LTS Kernel, alles gut, okay wunderbar, passt, mal mal ein Docker,
clean, ne, wie war das, prune, irgendwas, genau, oder all, konnte man nicht einfach
so machen, der Soundtrack ist richtig hogge, das ist Crypt of the Necrodancer, so gut,
noch einmal Reboot, dann sollten wir es eigentlich geschafft haben, also gut, das hat mich jetzt
ein bisschen abgelenkt, jetzt kann ich erzählen, kann ich erzählen was wir heute davor haben,
ich trinke erstmal was, und ich gucke mal in Chat, der Shopkeeper, das kommt am Ende,
mal hier, der Shopkeeper ist am Ende am Start, hier, da ist der Shopkeeper dabei, ja, don't
show again, das juckt dir nicht, da shows trotzdem again, ne, nicht Chrome, FireFox,
please, warum ist da Adidas drinne mittlerweile, alter geht weg, eh, dismiss, dismiss, piss dich
Alde, heckle, oh man sollte hier nicht nach random Sachen suchen, oh, Frosch ist im Krankenhaus
wegen Knie, oh das ist aber blöde, Knie sucked, die ist hyper, hyper sucked, was hast du gemacht,
mein so alt bist du noch nicht, ich vermute mal, dass du der Frosch von YouTube bist, aber
Ackle, bist du aber Ackle, der Ackle Frosch, falls den irgendjemand kennt noch, so, jetzt
lass mal aufmachen irgendwie, der Ackle Frosch, gib mal Wipp, ne, so einfach ist das nicht,
nur weil man der Ackle Frosch ist, gibt es noch keinen Wipp, die Teerverletzung, aber
Knie ist Kacke, Knie ist ähnlich, im Alter kriegst du es dann noch in der Hüfte und so
was, das ist Sachen, das ist wirklich Kacke, also Knie und Hüfte suckt einfach mal richtig,
will das Ding hier eigentlich nicht, Logitech Hub hat meine DPI auf 800 gesetzt, geil, das
ist natürlich die Nachricht des Tages, das ist wichtig, dass mich das da drüber notifiziert,
dass ich Bescheid weiß, so, dann versuche ich euch jetzt mal zu erklären, was wir heute
machen, aber ich muss erstmal irgendwie ein bisschen so in, wir machen jetzt Streamlaune
kommen, das hat mich jetzt ein bisschen abgelenkt mit der VM, dass die nicht funktioniert hat,
ich leg schon mal neues Projekt an, das schadet ja nichts hier, Domain Champ, da kann man
sich schon so ungefähr wahrscheinlich ableiten um was es geht, was haben wir denn eigentlich
für eine.NET Version mittlerweile installiert, 7, genau,.NET New Console, ja passt, da sind
wir, dann öffnen wir das mal und dann erzähle ich euch was wir vorhaben, ich habe schon
ein paar Sachen vorbereitet diesmal, wir werden nicht alles komplett from scratch machen,
weil manche Sachen sind einfach langweilig, die muss man nicht zum 870. Mal machen. So,
beste, eine Runde Hello World. Gut, funktioniert alles. Okay, dann versuche ich euch mal zu
erklären, was ich vorhabe, und zwar ist das eine Sache, die habe ich schon länger vor,
da mache ich mir die letzten paar Jahre schon über Gedanken, wie man das am besten machen
könnte. Und zwar, ich habe bei mindestens 5 verschiedenen Domain-Anbieter, also Registrare
nennt sich das ja, bei mindestens 5 verschiedenen Domain-Registrare habe ich Domains, ich habe
sogar noch was bei Nitrado, bei Hetzner, bei Nitrado, bei Azure, nee, nee, Quatsch, nicht
Azure, privat habe ich keine bei Azure, bei Cloudflare, bei Cloudflare war Namecheap,
bei NameSilo und so komisch Dinge, ich habe bei relativ vielen Domain-Registrars Domains
und ich würde gerne mitkriegen, bzw. ich würde gerne überwachen, wann die ablaufen,
manche will ich nicht verlängern, manche vergesse ich vielleicht zu verlängern, weil
manchen ist vielleicht irgendwas mit dem Auto, mit dem Auto verlängern kaputt oder ich will
dem keine Paypal-Auto-Bezahl-Dings geben, was auch immer, ich hätte gerne einfach eine
Übersicht, wie lange meine Domains noch gültig sind und was mich echt gewundert hat ist,
warum blinkt meine Maus, meine Maus soll nicht blinken, Sekunde, Logitech Hub, auf Logitech
Hub, geh auf, no thanks, Logitech Hub, please, nein, ich will einfach nur meine Maus einstellen
machen, on-Board-Memory, ok, natürlich on-Board-Memory, so, ich will mein RGB einstellen, RGB stellt
man ein, ne, nicht Light Sync, doch, Effekt, off, Logo, off, ok, den Sinn davon verstehe
ich zwar nicht so genau, für was das da ist, aber ok, off, also ich hab ganz gerne RGB-Beleuchtung
an der Tastatur und so was, aber an der Maus mag ich persönlich nicht, doch, jetzt ist
weg, bin ich jetzt stehen geblieben, ja, ich hab, ich hab, es ist egal, ob der Akku hält
oder nicht, ich hab so ein Mauspad, was die Maus auflädt, wenn man das drauf stellt,
Skiz von Logitech, das ist ein, was heißt denn das Teil, guck mal, ob das drauf steht,
gute Frage, warte mal, ja, G-Powerplay, ja genau, das ist das, das Ding, also ich hab
so eine G-, ich hab eine Pro Wireless, Logitech Pro Wireless, bin mittlerweile auch umgestiegen
auf kabellose Mäuse vor 2, 3 Jahren, ich hatte lange, lange Zeit noch Kabel, also ich
hab so eine Pro Wireless Maus, die ist wirklich nice und so einen Mauspad, was die Maus gleich
mit aufladen kann, das einzige, was du machen musst, du musst unten so einen, anstatt,
anstatt die normale Klappe, musst du da so eine Klappe mit so einem passenden Empfänger
dafür, was weiß ich, so ein Induktionsding, musst du da unten rein machen, das macht
es irgendwie 2 Gramm schwerer, nicht wirklich der Rede wert und dann lädt sich die Maus
automatisch auf und sie expire, das ist eigentlich eine ganz coole Idee, was Logitech da hatte.
Okay, so, wo bin ich denn stehen geblieben, ich wollte euch erzählen, was wir machen,
also ich hab relativ viele Domains rumfliegen, bei, wie gesagt, Nitrado, Cloudflare, Namecheap,
Silo, alle möglichen Dinger und ich überleg mir die ganze Zeit schon, wie man das irgendwie
gescheit überwachen kann, wann meine Domains ablaufen und es gibt ein paar Tools dafür,
aber die sind alle irgendwie nicht so doll, also es gibt zum Beispiel einmal, wenn man
mal bei GitHub guckt, da findet man sowas hier zum Beispiel, Domain-Exporter, Domain-Exporter,
blablabla und da sieht man, okay, von der Idee her macht das schonmal das Richtige, der stellt
einen Prometheus-Nodexporter bereit, oder Prometheus-Exporter bereit, der sagt, wann
die Domains ablaufen, ja, dann kriegt man dann zum Beispiel, aha, Domains-Google.com
läuft ab, das Dumme ist nur, die machen das über Whois-Abfragen und Whois-Abfragen funktionieren
halt einfach nur noch für die wenigsten Domains, macht mal Whois-Google.de und sowas
und dann guckt man, ob ihr seht, wann das abläuft, bei Google weiß ich es gar nicht,
aber bei den meisten Domains steht das gar nicht dabei, also du kriegst es überhaupt
nicht mehr raus, wenn deine Domains ablaufen über Whois-Abfrage, was ja auch irgendwo
in Ordnung ist, dann habe ich was gefunden, das ist irgendwie so ein extra, oh, wie heißt
das, Domain-Mod oder sowas, genau, dann gibt es so ein komisches PHP-Tool, was eigentlich
genau für sowas gemacht sein soll, sieht dann so aus, oh, ich bin blind, seh nix Leute,
so hell, egal, ich muss es euch gar nicht zeigen, ich mach lieber wieder zu, das kann das auch,
aber das unterstützt irgendwie die meisten Provider gar nicht, wo ich das abfragen will
und was ich gerne hätte, ich hätte gerne was, was man easy integrieren kann in Subbix
oder in Prometheus oder sonst wie was und da bleibt eigentlich bloß ein Custom Prometheus-Exporter
zu machen, der Domain-Infos abfragt, so und das muss ja auch halbwegs gut erweiterbar
sein, das heißt wir brauchen drei Sachen, wir brauchen eine.NET-Kommandos, muss keine
.NET-Anwendung sein, das könnte genauso gut eine Go-Anwendung sein oder Placingly Fast
Written in Rust, ja zum Beispiel, das kann man auch machen, das geht auch, das geht auch,
wenn man sich da drauf verlässt und dann irgendwie automatisch die Mails parsen will
oder sowas, ist auch, aber ganz ehrlich, Mail-Notifications, Mail-Alerts ist so das allerletzte Mittel, wenn
sonst nichts geht, zumal ich auch die Mails, wo ich mich da registriert habe, gar nicht
mal so unbedingt jetzt regelmäßig reingucke, wie cooler wäre es doch, wenn man die, ja
wie gesagt, das kann man machen, aber wie gesagt, ich finde Mail-Benachrichtigungen
immer so, das ist immer so das letzte, was wenn sonst nichts geht, kann man Mail-Benachrichtigungen
machen, außerdem kann man aus diesen Mail-Benachrichtigungen schlecht was rausparsen, weil die Mails alle
anders aufgebaut sind und ich möchte ja vielleicht auch mal so einen Graph haben mit meinen Domains,
die ablaufen, so als Übersicht und ich bin mir relativ sicher, das könnten noch deutlich
mehr Leute gebrauchen, Problem ist halt, auf hohes Daten kannst du dich nicht verlassen,
Mail ist so letzte Wahl, wenn sonst nichts geht, die allerletzte Wahl, wenn sonst nichts
geht, ist regelmäßig von Hand ins Web-Interface gucken oder Web-Scraping auf der Webseite
machen oder so, aber das braucht man eigentlich gar nicht, weil die allerallermeisten Domain-Registranten
bieten mittlerweile auch Apis an, z.B. wenn man hier Namecheap hat so was oder Name, also
auch wirklich so wirklich ganz, ganz billige Domain-Registrars, die auch wirklich die Seiten
auch schon aussehen wie aus dem letzten Jahrtausend und so was, da geht das, dann kann man mittlerweile
abfragen, muss das alles über einen anderen Browser machen, am besten aus der VM, dann
habe ich wirklich auch Dark Mode, also die meisten Domain-Registrars haben mittlerweile
Apis, wo man abfragen kann, wann läuft ein Domain ab, das heißt im Endeffekt braucht
man drei verschiedene Bestandteile, z.B. Cloudflare, Cloudflare kannst du auch per Api abfragen,
ja Cloudflare bräuchte DE-Domains, das wäre gut, ich glaube Cloudflare kannst du keine
DE-Domains posten, irgendwas war da, ich habe nämlich auch versucht meine Nitrado-Domain
umzuziehen und das ging irgendwie nicht, DE ging nicht, moin der Kommentator, so und deswegen
habe ich mir gedacht wir können ein Tool bauen, was erstmal nur mein Zeug abdeckt, aber nachdem
ich mir relativ sicher bin, dass das noch mehr Leute brauchen, also wir brauchen eine.NET
Domaino-Zeilen-Anwendung, die folgendes macht, die verschiedene, ich nenne es mal Plugins
hat, das heißt wir müssen heute noch ein bisschen was advancederes machen mit Interfaces
und Reflections, nicht wirklich Plugins in Form von, dass du irgendwie Source-Code nachlädst,
affiliierst und dann als Plugin laufen lässt, aber dass man relativ einfach neue Domain-Registrache
unterstützen kann, also wir brauchen eine Konsolen-Anwendung, die einmal einen Prometheus-Exporter
bereitstellt für jede Domain, quasi mit dem expired Datum, also irgendein Timestamp, expired
Unix-Time, dann und dann, dann muss das Ding Kommando-Zeilen-Argumente unterstützen, dass
man sagen kann, zum Beispiel, also exemplarisch, das gibt es ja nicht, also man sagt Domain-Champ,
minus, minus, keine Ahnung, Hetzner, Punkt, oder Hetzner minus, wir machen es mal nach
.NET Konvention, Hetzner, was würde ich tauchen, 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, so dass das, keine Ahnung,
tauchen und, und, User, Kackel und dann haben wir irgendwie Name, Silo, minus, minus, User,
0W, add gmail.com, Passwort, 1, 2, 3, 5, 6, irgendwie sowas in der Richtung, ja, oder
tauchen, oder tauchen oder so, sowas, sowas in der Richtung, das kann man dann aufrufen
und dann hat es im Hintergrund für die jeweiligen Anbieter-Implementierung, wie man über die
jeweilige Anbieter-AP Domain-Information abfragen kann, das Ganze wird dann über slashmetrics
auf einem Webserver bereitgestellt, dass jeder da hergelaufenen Zappix oder Prometheus den
Kram abfragen kann und man das verwenden kann.
Dass das gebraucht wird, prinzipiell sieht man ja auch daran, mal gucken, die Dinger sind
relativ beliebt hier, ja, aber wie gesagt, Whois-Informationen kannst du dich nicht wirklich
gut drauf verlassen, also man sieht schon, dass das Leute benutzen, aber ich finde es
halt ein bisschen suboptimal, wie das hier gemacht ist, erstens brauchst du Whois-Informationen,
nicht jede Domain kriegst du über Whois raus, wann die abläuft und du musst von Hand die
Domains angeben.
Ich würde gerne sagen können, ey, check mal alle Domains, die ich bei Hetzner habe und
check mal alle Domains, die ich bei Namesilo habe oder bei Namecheap oder GoDaddy oder
was es da nicht alles gibt und dann mach mir einfach in meine Metrics rein, welche Domain
wann abläuft, fertig, also das Ding soll unterstützen, Kommandozeilen Argumente, also
wenn schon dann auch gescheit, ja, das Ding soll unterstützen, Kommandozeilen Argumente,
Environment Variablen und Config Files, Config Files würde ich sagen in Yammel und in JSON,
das ist so der Standard, Inni und Tommel sparen wir uns mal, müssen es ja nicht übertreiben,
JSON Config oder Yammel Config, Environment Variablen oder halt direkt Kommandozeilen
Argumente.
Insofern ganz praktisch, weil nicht jeder ruft das Ding so über Kommandozeile aus,
manche möchten es beispielsweise auch im Docker Container und da ist es oftmals einfacher,
Environment Variablen zu setzen als Kommandozeilen Argumente hinten noch anzugeben und ja, zu
guter Letzt muss das Ding natürlich dann implementiert werden für alle möglichen Anbieter.
Wir machen es testweise jetzt mal für Namesilo, warum, nee warte mal, nee, nicht Namesilo,
ja, wir machen das testweise mal mit Namecheap, so eine Testimplementierung zum rausfinden,
welche Domain wie lange noch gültig ist, weil Namecheap hat, Cloudflare hat auch, also
viele haben das, aber Namecheap kann ich mir einfach einen Fake Account machen, die haben
eine Sandbox API, da kann man sich einen kompletten Sandbox Account anlegen und damit rumbasteln
wie man will.
Aber erstmal müssen wir, ja das ist der Plan, das heißt, wir müssen heute, nachdem wir
das Plugin mäßig machen, müssen wir uns heute mal ein bisschen mit Reflection und Interfaces
und automatisch instanzieren und sowas, das angucken, also ich werde es Plugin mäßig
machen, genauso wie du schreibst, dass man relativ einfach neue Anbieter hinzufügen
kann, also machen wir mal schon mal einen Ordner, nennen wir irgendwie Checks oder sowas, oder
Domain Checks oder wie nennt man das Ding, Provider, den ich nenne Checks, da kommen
die ganzen Sachen rein, ich habe schon ein paar Dinge vorbereitet, das muss ich mir gerade
mal hier im zweiten Bildschirm aufmachen, weil manche Sachen sind einfach langweilig,
die möchte man nicht, alles klar, also Ziel ist, ich schreibe das hier nochmal rein, also
wir wollen an config unterstützen, wo wir sowas unterstützen, config jammel, config jimmel,
weil sich ja die Leute immer nicht einigen können, wie man den Crap schreibt, Leute,
was sagt ihr, jammel oder jimmel, ich persönlich bin ja Team jammel mit A ausgeschrieben,
aber es gibt auch viele, die stehen auf jimmel, Jason, Tommel, na komm, wir können es, wenn
wir Tommel machen, können wir auch noch Inni machen und sowas, wir übertreiben es, wir
übertreiben es mal nicht, so und das ganze werden wir übrigens zum ersten Mal mit System
Command Line machen, was uns da ein bisschen hilft bei, was ist das offizielle Microsoft
Command Line Framework für Command Line Anwendungen, xml, boah nee, hör mal auf, ich meine xml
könnten wir da genauso unterstützen, so, dann wollen wir hier Plugins für die unterschiedlichen
Anbieter wollen wir haben und config wollen wir dann noch haben über environment oder
CLI options, so und dann muss natürlich noch was dabei, was das im Hintergrund ausführt
die ganze Zeit, dann gibt es noch einen Prometheus Exporter, der die Daten bereitstellt über
den Webserver, so das heißt wir können schon mal die ganzen Crampel mal hinzufügen als
Packages, was wir brauchen, also wir brauchen auf jeden Fall Prometheus.net für den eigenen
Exporter, das stimmt und du kannst fast auch jedes Jammel in Jason konvertieren, leider
nicht alles, wenn du so Course Referenzen und sowas so ganz abgedreht Jammel Features
verwendest, dann geht es nicht, aber das meiste Jammel kannst du wieder zurück in Jason übersetzen,
aber ich kann meine config Datei so aufbauen, dass das geht, da brauche ich quasi nur ein
Puzzler, gibt es eigentlich gescheite Jammel Libraries für.NET, also ich kenne bloß
das hier und das ist, ja, ah ja, es ist vorhanden, wirklich Spaß zu arbeiten, macht es nicht
wirklich, aber wir brauchen Jason.net, weil Jason.net beste, immer noch lieber wieder
eingebaute Puzzler, dann brauchen wir System Command Line, das ist glaube ich nur als
Preview Package verfügbar, ich glaube das war es wahrscheinlich, ich mache ja meistens
einen großen Bogen um Jammel, den einzigen Vorteil, den ich persönlich den Jammel sehe,
ist, dass du Kommentare reinschreiben kannst, also wie gesagt, wirklich den einzigen großen
Vorteil an Jammel sehe ich echt, dass du Kommentare reinschreiben kannst, alles andere brauchst
kein Jammel für, wenn die Jason mal erweitern, dass du Kommentare reinschreiben kannst,
ich bin nicht happy, ich werde nie wieder Jammel verwenden, wobei man das ja so nicht
sagen kann, weil jedes gültige Jason Dokument auch gültiges Jammel Dokument ist, also könntest
du eigentlich Jason schreiben und in Jammel speichern, was aber mit Endungen Jammel speichern,
was aber halt auch irgendwie unsinnig ist, also das ist das was wir machen, das werden
wir bei weitem heute nicht hinkriegen, das sage ich euch gleich und ich muss mir mal ein
paar Sachen, ich kopiere mir mal ein paar Sachen rüber und ich erzähle was zu, Jason 5 gibt
doch schon Comments echt, gleich mal her, was Jason 5 gibt es Comments, wer unterstützt
Jason 5, das probiere ich jetzt mal kurz aus, achja das geht, ok das heißt im Endeffekt,
das heißt im Endeffekt, das muss ich jetzt mal ausprobieren, das muss ich mal ausprobieren,
ob das wirklich funktioniert oder ob das Jason.net überhaupt unterstützt, dann machen wir hier
config.json, so ich kopiere das mal rein, nicht diesen ganzen Mist hier, wir kopieren
mal Comments rein, Comments und ja keine Ahnung hier, Keckel, so, also Wim ist schonmal
der Meinung, ganz böse darf man nicht, aber gut was Wim im Syntax Highlighting sagt ist
jetzt erstmal nicht so wild, Microsoft Extension Configuration, ja gut, die setzen ja wahrscheinlich
standardmäßig auf den eingebauten Jason Pulser, können aber auch, Jason.net kann
man glaube ich auch mittlerweile immer noch die Config überschreiben, dass sie das dafür
verwenden, wie lange braucht man um Terraform zu lernen, die denke ich relativ zackig, also
es gibt viele Beispiele für und wenn man praktische Anwendungsfälle hat, geht das eigentlich,
also ich denke mal wenn du dich damit eine Woche ordentlich auseinandersetzt, dann kommst
du schon gut mit klar, so das muss ich jetzt mal ausprobieren, ob das funktioniert, also
Jason Convert, E-Serialize, testen wir das einfach mal, ob das funktioniert, achso File,
Read All Text, Config, Yeson, Keckel, so, was nicht Channel Writer, Console, Write Line,
hey, das unterstützt ja mittlerweile Kommentare, okay ich hab nix gesagt Leute, vielleicht
sollten wir einfach doch kein Jaml unterstützen, weil Jaml zackt, das einzige warum ich Jaml
jemals verwendet habe ist für Kommentare, ich mein du kannst in Jaml ein paar abgedrehte
andere Sachen machen, du kannst beispielsweise Referenzen machen und sowas, aber das macht
kaum einer in Jaml, komm wir unterstützen trotzdem Jaml, aber ist gut zu wissen, dass
die Kommentare können, warum Jaml zackt, weil ich finde es schlecht lesbar ist, der hauptsächliche
Grund von Jaml war ja, dass es ein lesbares Jason ist, das Problem ist nur, ich finde
Jaml nicht wirklich lesbar, du musst gucken nach Einrückung, es wahrscheinlich so ein
bisschen ähnliche Argumente wie Vor- und Pro- und Kontrapasseneinrückung, aber ich
mag Jaml Einrückung nicht, gar nicht so sehr, also auch, aber nicht so sehr, weil es schlecht
lesbar ist und weil du dann so Sachen hast, du hast zum Beispiel ein Jaml, guck mal, wenn
du ein Jaml File hast, also früher musstest du sowas in Jaml oben noch machen, brauchst
du ja mittlerweile weiter nicht mehr, du kannst sagen config, so eins, zwei, das ist jetzt
ein Array, so und jetzt sagst du halt aus Versehen drei, so und dann ist das schon einmal
kein gültiges Jaml mehr, ja dann meistens fällt das relativ schnell auf, aber es gibt,
wenn es ein bisschen genästet ist, durchaus Probleme, dass man das nicht direkt sieht
und was ich richtig doof finde, wenn du Jaml Copy Pastest, weil Copy Pasten machen ganz
gerne mal irgendwelche Editon-Probleme, dass dann doch die Einrückung falsch ist und so
was, das ist, und man kann Jason auch ohne Probleme ordentlich formatieren, so dass man
das, dass man das liest, selbst wenn ich jetzt hier sehe, guck mal, angeblich ist ja sogar
abschließendes Komma erlaubt mittlerweile, guck dir mal Leute, das ist ja mal richtig
hyper modern, abschließendes Komma in Jason erlaubt und Kommentare in Jason erlaubt mittlerweile,
da habe ich immer weniger Gründe überhaupt Jaml zu verwenden, der Kommentator schreibt,
ich bin gerade echt froh wieder über ein C Sharp Projekt, wir bräuchten mal ein Wub
Love Emote oder, haben wir irgendwas passendes dafür, haben wir gar nicht, wir haben Wubwurst,
aber das ist vielleicht nicht das Richtige jetzt, das muss ich mir mal aufschreiben,
ja, machen wir gleich, freue mich immer über Projekte beim Memeboard Versandtun, 4er Champ,
ja, 4er Champ machen wir demnächst auch weiter, aber Wub Love, irgendwie so ein Keks, der
so ein Herzchen hält, ich glaube das ist ganz nett, werde ich mal beauftragen, werde ich
mal beauftragen, okay, also ich bin begeistert, dass das alles schon unterstützt wird, gut,
ich werde mal ein paar Sachen kopieren Leute, weil ich habe mir im Vorfeld schon ein bisschen
Gedanken gemacht und wir werden nicht alles komplett von Hand machen, weil vieles ist
eklig und auch langweilig jedes Mal neu von Hand zu machen, also, wir bauen das Ganze
mit Plugins, dass du quasi unterschiedlichen Domain Registrare über so Art Plugins unterstützen
kannst und chat, wer ist high IQ, wer weiß, was ist das erste, was man machen muss, wenn
man ein per Plugin erweiterbares Tool programmieren will, was ist das erste, was man definieren
muss, an was sich die Plugins halten sollen, okay, das ist vielleicht zu vage gestellt,
aber vielleicht kommt irgendjemand, eine Paybot, DLCs oder sowas, nee, das ist nicht richtig,
vielleicht ist es zu vage formuliert, ich glaube das weiß man nicht, worauf ich raus
will, ich meine ein Interface braucht man, eine XML-Config, man braucht ein Interface,
so eine Art Schema, genau, so eine Art Schema braucht man, wo man sagt, hey, das muss ein
Plugin haben, dass es eben als Plugin angesehen wird und da habe ich schon was, guckt mal,
da habe ich im Vorfeld überlegt, mal gucken, mal gucken, inwieweit das funktioniert, ja,
sowas hier, machen wir da als, jedes Plugin muss eine XML-Config, ja klar, und XML und
zusätzlich noch INI, und am besten braucht das eine Abhängigkeit auf eine Webseite, die
von dem Fly-Cobol auf IBM Mainframes kompiliert, dass es geladen werden kann, das ist, dann
ist es, nur dann ist es gut, so, ich habe mir gedacht, unser Interface, braucht es das
Public für die Properties, äh, das Public braucht es überhaupt nicht, das ist verkehrt,
das kann man weglassen, das kann man weglassen, so, also so in der Richtung habe ich mir das
überlegt, ihr seht, es gibt ja noch nicht allzu viele Sachen, also was ich mir gedacht
habe ist, damit man ein Plugin, also ein Plugin ist in dem Fall eine Klasse, die einen bestimmten
Domain-Registrat checken kann, wann Domains ablaufen, also man würde dann zum Beispiel
sowas machen, hier Public-Class, Namecheap oder so, I-Domain-Check, und dann müsste diese
Klasse eben alles das implementieren, damit das funktioniert, ich habe mir das folgendermaßen
überlegt, wo ist die Domain-Checker-Factory-Factory-Singleton-Manager, ja, vielleicht kommen wir auch noch so weit
heute, also ich dachte, wir machen das folgendermaßen, damit das schön erweiterbar ist, und natürlich
Blazingly Fast Written in Rust, auch, auch ganz wichtig, ja, die Plugins, das kommt ja
wahrscheinlich hauptsächlich von mir oder irgendwie über Pull-Requests vielleicht von
irgendwelchen Leuten, aber so ist es einfacher, da was zu implementieren, also ich dachte mir,
wir machen das so, jedes Plugin kriegt eine Description und kriegt eine URL, dass man
einfach einen Link hat zu dem jeweiligen Domain-Registrat, wenn man nachgucken will,
dann ein Intervall, in dem gecheckt wird, dann eine Register-Methode, das ist quasi gedacht,
dass man sich, ich bin mir nicht ganz sicher, ob das so funktioniert, wie ich mir das vorstelle,
aber müssen wir gleich mal ausprobieren, eine Register-Methode, die wird initial einmalig
aufgerufen, wo man dann zum Beispiel Kommando-Zeilen-Argumente angeben kann, weil es ist ja so, wir wollen
ja, dass man das so aufrufen kann, also, dass man zum Beispiel sagen kann, ich möchte das
Hetzner-Plugin verwenden und das Hetzner-Plugin braucht ein Argument-Token und es kriegt dann
diesen Wert, also sprich, die Plugins müssen quasi dynamisch Kommando-Zeilen-Parameter
oder generell Optionen registrieren können, diese Optionen können dann entweder per Config-Datei,
per Enviren mit Variable oder per CLI übergeben werden, aber es soll natürlich auch per CLI
möglich sein, es soll natürlich auch per CLI eine Hilfe auftauchen und sowas, das heißt,
wir brauchen irgendwie so eine Art Register, wo dann die Plugins sagen können, hey, ich
hätte gerne ein Passwort, ein Token und ein Username und sowas, dann taucht das halt,
mal gucken, wie man das sagt.
So, ja, das kriegt sowas ähnliches wie App-Config übergeben, wo das dann, das habe ich auch
schon gebaut, zumindest im Ansatz sowas, wo dann das Plugin sich quasi registrieren kann,
welche Optionen es haben möchte und sich die Optionen dann, nachdem es registriert hat,
auch direkt laden kann und setzen kann und wenn das Plugin zum ersten Mal geladen wird,
also so wirklich quasi jetzt geht es los, dann wird einmal INIT aufgerufen, dann kann
das Plugin zum Beispiel checken, sind meine Parameter, die ich übergeben bekommen habe,
alle richtig und irgendwas funktioniert nicht und wenn was nicht funktioniert, dann kann
das Ding den Error-Code zurückgeben und hier false returnen bei INIT oder es returnt true
und kein Error-Code und dann ist alles gut und jedes Mal, wenn die Domains gecheckt werden
sollen, gibt es dann, wird dann run aufgerufen, run wird mit dem Cancellation-Token aufgerufen,
also sprich, das kann man asynchron machen und man kann es abbrechen, so und dann gibt
es noch sowas wie Domain-Check-Result, das konnten wir bei der Gelegenheit eigentlich
auch gerade mal einbauen, Domain-Check-Result ist dann quasi sowas wie String, der Name
quasi und datetime-expires-add, was ist das, ja, dann brauchen wir noch einen Typ abconfig,
da kann ich mir schon ein bisschen was kopieren, das habe ich schon ein bisschen was vorbereitet,
so ungefähr habe ich mir das gedacht, ich hoffe man versteht so was ich mir denke, wie
man das machen könnte, so dann verschieben wir den Crampel mal, Domain-Check verschieben
wir mal dahin und dann sagen wir, wir wollen das verschieben nach, nein ich blödsinnig,
da ich das so gemacht habe, wir wollen das verschieben, gegen das verschieben nochmal
move to folder, checks, wenn er es jetzt richtig macht, passt er den Name und den Namespace
an, genau, da kommen dann die ganzen checks rein, app-config kommt in eine, was, wie findest
du die neue Rider-UI, wo gibt es da eine neue UI, das sieht aus wie immer, oder, echt, ok
das gucken wir uns jetzt mal an, settings-UI, ich habe das allerneueste, ja, hier, oh Leute
wollen wir das mal ausprobieren, sag mal, wollen wir lieber progas machen oder, komm
wir gucken uns das an, mich interessiert jetzt wie das aussieht, schau Main-Menu in separate
Toolbar, ich habe keine Ahnung was es tut und was es macht, ok save, das sieht eigentlich
ganz nett aus, das sieht eigentlich ganz, also es hat mir jetzt auf den ersten Blick
schon mal gefallen, ja, da braucht man keinen mit, naja gut hier, das Hamburger Menü kann
man sich jetzt drüber streiten, ob man das wirklich auf Desktop-Anwendungen haben will,
hat er, hat er mit der Farbschema und ganzen Krämpel umgestellt, Problems, ok, ok, wie
geht Steuerung A noch, settings, ok das geht immer noch, achso hier, hier kann man das
Hamburger Menü ausschalten, ah, ok, ja aber das bleibt ja immer noch da, dann ist natürlich
auch unsinnig, dann können wir das auch wieder weg machen, ich muss mal kurz, themes, appearance,
visual, studio, dark, ah, das ist gut, mache mal abyssi kleiner, abyssi pet gerade so, Leute
ich muss sagen ich finde das tatsächlich gerade mal übel, ich glaube das lasse ich so, das
sieht, das sieht, das sieht ein bisschen cleaner aus, muss ich sagen, wie findet ihr es, also
ich muss sagen ich finde es ansprechender als das alte, weil von der Funktionsumfang und
allem wird sich hier aber schlicht und ergreifend nichts tun, wahrscheinlich einfach nur ein
bisschen reskin, der Run Bereich sieht auch ganz gut aus, ja, es hat ein bisschen was
moderneres, sieht nicht aus wie 2005, es sieht tatsächlich, ja finde ich auch, es hat ein
bisschen was von visual studio code, aber es ist gar nicht schlecht, viele Sachen haben
sich halt sehr inspirieren lassen von visual studio code und ganz im Ernst, ich bin nicht
böse darum, wenn sich die meisten Tools ein bisschen aneinander orientieren, dass man
ein bisschen einfacher reinkommt, ich lasse das Hamburger Menü trotzdem mal da, warum
nicht, die Leiste wird ja nach wie vor so groß sein, weil oben das Run ist, ja finde
es nicht übel, hat was, ok, App-Config verschieben wir mal in eine eigene Datei und Program,
ja Domain Check Result, ja komm, wir verschieben es auch mal in eine eigene Datei, weil warum
nicht, hallo, warum möchte er das nicht in eine eigene Datei verschieben, dann, warum
will er das nicht, ach ne, das liegt wahrscheinlich, weil ich nicht auf Class bin, ok, es juckt
hier nicht, eh, irgendwie ein bisschen broken gerade, irgendwie etwas broken, ah jetzt,
jetzt mag er, ok so ist nice, also wir machen jetzt mal, wir fangen jetzt einfach mal an,
wie gesagt, ich habe schon ein paar andere Sachen noch gebastelt, die wir uns gleich
angucken werden, Beispiel, weil ich da kein Bock habe, das hier, weil das langweilig ist,
ich würde gerne das in ein eigenes File verschieben, was hat der eigentlich für Schmerzen, warum
will er die Sachen nicht in ein eigenes File verschieben, ohne dass ich da drüber was stehen
habe, doch komplett angeblieben, das werden wir heute sonst nicht mehr brauchen und ich
glaube das war's, wir brauchen ihn, what are you making, I try to create a tool with a custom
Prometheus exporter, that can check the expire date of domains via the provider APIs and
does not rely on the whois entries, which can be extended via plugins for all major domain
registers, registrars, I don't know, 5 hat time, englisch 5 hat time angesagt, Leute,
we are all sitting in one boat, Leute, okay, also wo sind wir stehen geblieben, ja, genau,
also wir bauen mal so einen Testweise, so einen Check, also Public, klar ist, wie das alles
aufgerufen wird und mit dem exporter und so machen wir dann da, registrar ist das, wo
du deine Domain registrierst, die dann beispielsweise auch Verträge und Sachen haben mit diesem
komischen Konsortium für Domains und ich blicke da ehrlich gesagt nicht genau durch, wie
da die genauen Wege sind, da müsste ich mal meinen Exkollege fragen, der beim Denik früher
gearbeitet hat, der betete das im Schlaf runter, ich blicke da beide zusammen hängen
ehrlich gesagt nicht so genau durch, zumindest bei einem Registrar, dort kannst du halt beispielsweise
sagen, ich will maxfps.de haben und die haben meistens auch DNS Server dafür, allerdings
kannst du auch sagen, hey, ich registriere mir die Domain bei Namecheap, aber verwende
Cloudflare DNS Server, das funktioniert auch, Aufruf an alle, dass sie ihre Prime-Subs nicht
verfallen lassen, nicer Sellout-Versuch, Leute, also ihr habt Devil's urgent gehört, lasst
eure Prime-Subs nicht verfallen, weil das ist extrem, wenn Prime-Subs verfallen und
mal ganz davon abgesehen, jetzt mal ohne Scheiß, selbst wenn ihr mir euren Prime-Sub nicht
gebt, ich freue mich natürlich, wenn ich den Prime-Sub kriege, ich bin happy über
jeden Prime-Sub, aber ich könnte natürlich auch jedem x-beliebigen anderen geben auf
Twitch, bloß nicht Bezos das Geld überweisen, du hast Prime gekündigt, ja dann kannst
du auch dein Prime-Sub nicht verfallen lassen, weil du hast ja kein Prime mehr, brainwots.cs,
Dankeschön für den Sub, wir machen jetzt mal so eine Testklasse, sagen wir mal, was
ich Namecheap, Check, nennen wir das mal, der implementiert, IDomain-Check, Implement
Missing Members, Description, schenken wir uns, URL, schenken wir uns, Intervall, schenken
wir uns nicht, Intervall, sage ich mal, from minutes 15, alle 15 Minuten abfragen, ich
meine ganz ehrlich, einmal am Tag würde auch voll und ganz reichen oder einmal die Stunde,
ja machen wir einmal die Stunde, reicht ja voll und ganz aus, einmal in der Stunde abzufragen,
wann die Domains expiren, ich muss nicht alle 15 Minuten abfragen, wann die Domains expiren,
alle Stunde ist schon, reicht eigentlich, also wir machen mal Testweise, wir machen
es mal zum ausprobieren, machen das jetzt tatsächlich mal alle 5 Sekunden, weil ich
will da testen, ob alles ordentlich funktioniert, Spiderschweine, Dankeschön für den Sub,
so, jetzt müssen wir natürlich gucken, dass wir hier irgendwas sinnvolles mit anfangen,
run, gut bei run machen wir genau mal eine Sache, run, kecke, return, new, äh Quatsch,
Async, was, ähm, return, new, Domain Check Result, wir können übrigens Domain Check
zu einem Rekord machen, ein bisschen neue C Sharp Features verwenden, das hier ist In
Hit und das hier ist Required, äh, ging das nicht so, habe ich nicht die richtige C Sharp
Version hier eingestellt, zeig mal her, C Sharp 11 will ich haben, bam, Required, genau,
jetzt kann man sowas hier machen, Domain Check, expires add, ja, zufälligerweise, now und
der Domain Name ist Wublaws.tv zum Beispiel, reicht da zum testen mal voll und ganz aus,
Abfragen reichen einmal im Monat, einmal im Monat ist vielleicht ein bisschen wenig,
du willst ja ab und zu auch, dass sich das aktualisiert, so nach dem Motto, ah Leute,
noch 14 Tage, noch 7 Tage, Achtung, Warning, 7 Tage, achtet mal drauf, wieso schreibt man
denn C Sharp immer dieses E-Force Interface, ist das nicht irrelevant, doch ist egal, das
ist egal, du kannst das auch, du kannst das ohne I schreiben, du kannst, ähm, das nennen
wie du willst, es hat sich so eingebürgert, dass man I davor schreibt, ich gehe mal davon
aus, dass es in Java ähnliche Sachen gibt, vielleicht jetzt nicht bei Interfaces, aber
dass man vor bestimmte Konstrukte, bestimmte Priefixes davor schreibt, das erinnert mich
ein bisschen dran, wie die Leute in C früher immer den Typ reingeschrieben haben, so nach
dem Motto, int blub gleich eins war dann int i blub gleich eins und sowas, Java schreibt
man auch davor, hier dann, genau, ja stimmt, in Java schreibst du Imp Impel hinten dran
und sowas, ja genau, das muss man auch nicht machen, aber es hat sich, hat sich so ein
bisschen eingebürgert, Essen ohne Await, naja, das heißt ja nicht, dass man hier nicht Await
braucht drinne, weil in Wirklichkeit müsstest du ja eigentlich sowas machen, HTTP Client
und dann müsstest du ja hier den API, den API Call machen und den Awaiten, jetzt zum
Testen nicht, aber man in Zukunft wirst du höchstwahrscheinlich brauchen, das I kommt
von Microsoft, die haben sich ja die Guidelines ausgedacht, ich brauche mal ein bisschen was
entspannendes kurz, das ist mir zu anstrengend, ja, kann man öfters laufen, aber das finde
ich, Nintendo muss sich immer entspannen, so, so machen wir das, gut, jetzt muss ich mal
kurz in mich gehen, wie wir das jetzt gescheit machen, also, wir haben jetzt so mal eine Test
hier, da mache ich einfach Return True und Registrar, ja, da gibt es noch nichts, mache
ich einfach gar nichts, was, achso, Error ist Nix, Null, wunderbar, haben wir so eine
Minimal Implementierung, können wir mal gucken, wie wir das Ganze jetzt machen, URL lassen
wir frei, Description lassen wir frei, so, jetzt haben wir zumindest schon mal eine Klasse
den Interface implementiert, jetzt muss ich mir mal aus den Fingern saugen, wie das mit
Reflection noch mal funktioniert, weil es ist ja so, hier gibt es jetzt, Moment, ich
schiebe das mal, also hier gibt es jetzt ja dann später vielleicht mal 15, 15 Anbieter,
die unterstützt werden, ja, in dem Fall haben wir jetzt hier Namecheap, aber das kann dann
auch Asher sein, Google Cloud, Hetzner, GoDaddy, NameSilo, Nitrado, was auch immer, alles was
eine API hat, theoretisch muss es auch nicht mal eine API haben, theoretisch könnte man
in so einer Plugin auch im Hintergrund Web Scraping über irgendwie einen Chrome machen,
das wollen wir aber nicht übertreiben, so, und jetzt müssen wir ja feststellen, beim
Starten des Programms, was gibt es eigentlich alles, man könnte jetzt natürlich hergehen
und sagen, ja, ist ja überschaubar, wir machen jetzt einfach einen Array, wobei das ja nicht
sondern nicht Plugin-like wäre, aber wir machen jetzt einfach einen Array, Checks, View, so,
und dann sagen wir jetzt einfach, bei nicht Checks, View, machen wir hier, I-Domain-Check,
oh, Checks, New, und dann könnte ich sagen, ja, New, Namecheap, Check und so was, und
als nächstes New, bla, bla, bla, Check und New, sowieso was, das ist natürlich nicht
so fein, weil jedes Mal, wenn ich in neue Implementierungen dazu haue, muss ich das
hier eintragen, es wäre natürlich viel cooler, wenn das ganze Auto discovert, und dann bin
ich mir aus dem Kopf, ehrlich gesagt, nicht wirklich sicher mehr, wie das funktioniert,
aber ich probiere das mal, ich glaube, das ist irgendwas mit Assembly, nee, nee, warte
mal, this, nee, Assembly ist schon richtig, Assembly, getCallingAssembly, das klingt
schon mal gut, getCallingAssembly, dann gibt es sowas wie Types, getTypes, das klingt
schon mal gut, getTypes, und jetzt müssen wir das filtern, where, type, also was wir
jetzt machen, das ist was, was du, also, was nicht unbedingt in jeder Sprache geht, also
du kannst in.NET beispielsweise, ohne einen Typ zu kennen, diesen Typ instanzieren, du
kannst, also du kannst jetzt damit, also was du machen kannst, du kannst gucken, was gibt
es denn für Typen, also zum Beispiel Namecheap ist ein Typ, was gibt es denn für Klassen,
die dieses Interface implementieren, ohne dass ich alle dann von Hand angeben muss, beziehungsweise
theoretisch sogar ohne dass ich zur Compile Zeit weiß, kann ich danach suchen, und dann
kann ich die laden, und auch benutzen, ohne dass ich die direkt hardcoded angeben muss,
also ich kann jetzt zum Beispiel sagen, ok, was gibt es denn für Typen, oder für Klassen,
die zum Beispiel dieses Interface implementiert haben, da bin ich mir aus dem Kopf, wie ging
das nochmal, das war so, das war so ein bisschen trickreich, ne, ne, ne, ne, ich muss die laden,
naja, ich muss die in dem Fall nicht laden, die sind Bestandteil von meinem Package, oder
von meinem Assembly, die sind da ja schon drinne, normalerweise hast du Recht, normalerweise
müsste ich dann gucken, ok, in welchem Datei, in welchem Pfeil, in welchem Verzeichnis liegen
Punkt CS Dateien, welche Klassen in diesen CS Dateien implementieren das, dann müsste
es diese importieren, ja aber so sind die ja alle dabei, ok, wir wollen schonmal nicht,
wir wollen schonmal is Interface false, not Interface, weil sonst erwische ich das Interface
selbst, da bin ich ein bisschen eingerostet, da weiß ich aus dem Kopf, so wie ging das
jetzt nochmal rauszukriegen, ob dieser Typ, wir fragen Stack Overflow, die Sharp Reflection
nennt sich das ganze, Check Type Implements Interface, ne, Check Types Implementing, how
to determine if blablabla, is assignable from, ok, das gibt auch ist, gibt auch bestimmt
is assignable to, in dem Fall ist Reflection sehr nice, also assignable, assignable to,
I domain check, aha, excellent, excellent, so und ich hab noch ne Idee, wir könnten noch
sagen, ne, lass mal, lass mal, was soll das Tool können, das soll bei verschiedenen Domain
Registrars abfragen können, wann deine Domains ablaufen, und zwar als Prometheus Exporter,
also dass du in dein Monitoring einbinden kannst, wann deine Domains ablaufen, bzw.
dass du dann auch wenn du ein Grafana dranhängst und Grafas, du kannst auch in Zappix einbinden,
dass du in dein Monitoring einbinden kannst, wann deine Domains ablaufen, weil die Möglichkeiten,
die es aktuell gibt, finde ich tatsächlich nicht, sondern nicht zufrieden stellen, es
gibt eben so ein komisches PHP Tool, was nicht alles unterstützt, was ich haben will, es
gibt Whois Exporter, die sich auf Whois Informationen verlassen, die zum größten Teil auch nicht
funktionieren bei meinen Domains, joa, was eigentlich, bringt es nicht so wirklich, ja,
ok, also lass mal kurz, Fivehead, Fivehead Time, das war es doch jetzt eigentlich, mehr
brauche ich, ich sag mal, To Array, der ist sicher, Bar, Check, Types, was brauche ich,
ich brauche Get Executing Assembly, der Unterschied, ahja, genau, du hast recht, auf der anderen
Seite ist es ja das gleiche, jetzt schauen wir mal, ob das funktioniert, also von der
Idee her, sollte der jetzt, diesen Check hier finden, ohne dass er weiß, zu diesem Zeitpunkt,
dass es den überhaupt gibt, weil er sucht alle Klassen, die iDomain Check implementieren,
schauen wir mal, ob das funktioniert, Check Types, was, warum tut er sich schwer irgendwie,
Console Write Line zu machen, so Check Types, First, so,.NET Run, gucken, ob das funktioniert,
das klappt, guck mal, der findet das, also ich durch, also, nur mal so, zum Beispiel,
wofür das cool ist, mal angenommen, ich würde jetzt was weiteres für, sagen wir Azure,
oder so, Azure, Azure Domain Check, oder sowas, einbauen, und das war es, mehr muss ich nicht
machen, achso, ich gebe ja nur das erste aus, Alter, bin ich bescheuert, ich gebe nur das
erste aus, ich muss eine Schleife machen, okay, wir machen das Cut nochmal rückgängig,
dass ihr seht, dass es funktioniert, Check Types, so, guck, so, jetzt findet er noch
diesen Type, und jetzt sag ich, okay, jetzt bau ich ein Plugin für Azure, so, zack, und
ich muss einfach nur dieses Interface implementieren, schon findet er die Klasse, also ich muss quasi
am Programm selbst nichts ändern, ich kann da auch nichts vergessen, einfach hier dieses
Interface implementieren, erfindet das, dass es ein gültiges Plugin ist, so, jetzt, müssen
wir gucken, dass wir das irgendwie instanziert kriegen, ich überlege gerade, wie machen
wir das jetzt, also, bei Linkin mal den C-Sharp-Test gemacht, nee, schick mal, lass mal, da gucken
wir gleich mal rein, da gucken wir gleich mal rein, wir machen mal den C-Sharp-Test,
ist das denn Hotspap fähig, nö, muss das komplett neu bauen dafür, schick mal den
Link zum, den gucken wir uns mal an, so, wie machen wir das jetzt am besten, also, ich
würde sagen, also wir machen jetzt eine Schleife über die Typen, die wir gefunden haben, dann
müssen wir davon eine Instanz anlegen, das ging glaube ich so, da gibt es mittlerweile,
Leute, korrigiert mich, wenn das nicht die richtige Variante ist, da gibt es mittlerweile
50 verschiedene Varianten, wie man per Reflection Sachen instanzieren kann, das ist das einzige,
was mir gerade auf den Kopf einfällt, Activator, Create Instance und dann muss man was sagen,
oder, Create Instance off, nee, doch, doch, doch, doch, Create Instance off, I-Domain-Check,
von diesem, nee, mach mal einen Kamm, Type, so, so muss man, ja, MonkaS-Reflection, funktioniert
das so, Check, warum Reflection, hast du auch ein Interface, ja, ich habe ein Interface
und jetzt, wie will ich die Klasse verwenden, ohne dass ich die, oder, erzähl mal, also,
das verstehe ich jetzt gerade nicht, was du meinst, und wie mache ich das, ohne Reflection,
vorher weiß ich, welche Checks es alles gibt, also, außer ich trage sie von Hand ein, doch,
doch, du kannst per Dependency Injection mehrere Implementierungen registrieren, das geht, und
dann musst du ein IEnumerable von dem Typ nehmen und dann kriegst du die ganzen Implementierungen,
das geht prinzipiell, aber, Dependency Injection weiß ja noch nicht, was ich alles für Klassen
habe, außerdem ist es gar nicht so schlecht, dann mach ich mal ein bisschen was mit Reflection,
du könntest sie wie bisher über Reflection Scan dann halt registrieren, mit dem was du
gefunden hast, oh, nee, muss man, braucht man ein LinkedIn-Account für, kann das sein,
dass das, was du kopiert hast, einfach ein bisschen gut ist, okay, ich mach mir kein LinkedIn,
damit ist es schon mal gestorben, zeig mal zwei unterschiedliche Seiten APs, die du aufrufen
willst, naja, neben Hetzner, Azure und Namecheap, zwei, drei komplett unterschiedliche Services,
oder wie, ich kann euch da grad nicht ganz folgen, willst du eigentlich mehrere Instanzen
von den Klassen haben, nee, nur eine, nur eine, nur eine, also ihr müsst mir das jetzt
schon ein bisschen genauer erklären, was ihr meint, ich kann euch da grad nicht so genau
folgen, ich mein, ich krieg ja aktuell weder raus, welche Klassen es gibt, die den Typ,
also die das Interface implementiert haben, noch krieg ich da vorne Instanz angelegt,
ich könnte wahrscheinlich irgendwie per Dependency Injection das machen, ich könnte wahrscheinlich
irgendwie sowas hier machen, wahr, host, das können wir mal ausprobieren, wir könnten
wahrscheinlich sagen, host, generic, host, nee, wie geht das, host, host builder, oh
fuck, Alter, was muss man dafür noch mal hinzufügen, dass das funktioniert, wo ist
das Nougat, irgendwas mit hosting ist es doch, hier Microsoft Extensions Hosting Abstraction
braucht man glaube, host gleich, host, builder, wie heißt das, den generic, host, builder,
ach fuck, Alter, ich hab keine Ahnung, wie das Zeug von Microsoft heisst, im Kopf, ich
brauch erstmal was, worauf ich das registrieren kann, das ist eine nackische Konsolenanwendung,
da ist grad noch nichts mit Dependency Injection oder sonst was, das probier ich grade, ok,
wir machen mal folgendes, ok, dass das Nougat Tab nicht da unten ist, kann man das Nougat
Tab wieder unten einblenden lassen, ach nee, hier ist es ja jetzt, ach ja, cool, im system.commandline.hosting
oder was, dann sollt ihr alles tabben, fault builder, host, das da, new host builder, genau,
jetzt haben wir alles, gleich, so, build, jetzt probieren wir das mal mit Dependency Injection
aus, ob das theoretisch überhaupt, das ist Rider mit dem neuen UI, die haben seit einer
Version ein neues experimentales UI, so und jetzt probieren wir das mal aus, ob das sinnvoll
ist, was der Chat sagt, weil manchmal, manchmal erzählt der Chat ja durchaus sinnvolle Sachen,
ich glaub host, konfigure services brauchen wir, service collection, so, jetzt kann ich
sagen, add singleton von diesem Typ, soll eigentlich funktionieren, es sieht tatsächlich
ein bisschen aus wie Visual Studio Code, aber finde ich gar nicht mal so schlecht, so, Typ,
so, das, das würde wahrscheinlich so funktionieren, und jetzt kann ich sagen, host, services,
jetzt service, nee, ey, Moment, Moment, Moment, Moment, Moment, Moment, nein, nein, nein,
so will ich das nicht machen, ich will, ich will die als idomain check registrieren, geht
aber so nett, oder, oder wie mach, wie mach ich das jetzt, ha, ach so, ah ja, ok, ich
hab jetzt irgendwelche Innereien von, von Microsoft, so, und nu, das ist zwar nicht
so, wie ich's machen wollte, aber ich mein, man lernt ja nicht aus, werden die automatisch
registriert, da bin ich mir nicht so sicher, ich glaube nicht, so, und jetzt würde ich
sagen, host, services, get services, alles services, idomain check, ob das jetzt funktioniert,
ok, aber kein Fehler, was hat der für Schmerzen mit, mit, mit, mit, mit, ok, das, ok, das
ist auch, das ist, Leute, das ist auch was, das ist, das ist eigentlich auch nicht schlecht,
wobei ich halt sagen muss, was für einen Vorteil habe ich von dependency injection
an der Stelle, eigentlich nix, außer, außer, dass wir dependency injection haben, um dependency
injection zu haben, ist so wirklich sinnvoll, ist es an der Stelle noch nicht, oder, aber
ok, hey, mein, ey mein, why not, ich glaube, wisst ihr was, Leute, der Einfachheit halber,
wir schenken uns das erst mal mit dependency injection, wir machen jetzt mal sowas, wir
machen jetzt mal, wie ich das vorher machen, vorher machen wollte, vorher wollte ich machen
hier, activator, create instance, offtype, so, bar, check, gleich, so, und das ist kein
objekt, sondern das ist ein, ich glaube, das muss man dann casten, ein idomain check, und
der ist auch garantiert nicht null, auch wenn dort etwas anderes meint, so, und jetzt könnten
wir noch an der Stelle einfach sowas machen hier, checks, machen einfach checks, und dann
sagen wir jetzt new, wollen wir machen mal ein dictionary, dictionary, ausname und domain
check, und dann können wir noch, check, add, der Name ist dann quasi Typ, name, und das
andere ist check, das geht doch auch, und jetzt habe ich auch ein dictionary mit allen
checks drin, so genau, so genau, so funktionieren, checks, values, first, dem host dann einfach
ein background worker hinzu, das ist eine gute Idee, das nennt sich ja hosted service,
nennt sich das dann, ja, vielleicht ist es doch so die bessere Variante, ich muss mal
ein bisschen ausprobieren, was mir da am besten gefällt, ach hier, ich will nicht die Fragen
mit antworten, ich will nur die Fragen haben, ach die antworten kommen unten, oder ach ne,
dahinten ist, Leute, ich will das ohne antworten haben, das gab es doch auch auf github, irgendein
Typ hat es doch, hier, linked in skill assessments, c, sharp, quiz, fuck man, man sieht da die
antworten drinnen, das ist ja dumm, also falls es einer findet, ohne dass man die antworten
sieht, oder dass man die antworten zumindest verstecken kann, wäre mir lieber, weil ich
will mir jetzt keinen extra linked in account, also das mit dem dependency injection und
dem background service, das überlege ich mir mal, ich muss erst mal ein bisschen ausprobieren,
ich muss erst mal überlegen, wie man das prinzipiell überhaupt aufbauen, also, so,
wir haben jetzt, ah, ich hab ne, der kram heißt immer check hinten dran, name cheap check,
das ist vielleicht gar nicht so blöd, dass das im background check heißt, aber für
den name muss ich das, und andere Sachen, name ends with check, gar nicht so schlecht, weil
dann könnte ich mich darauf verlassen, dass es auf jeden fall, dass da vorder name ist,
name, type, name, warte mal, no, type, name, dann starten wir hier den letzten back, so,
das enden wir dann hier unten, oops, nein, nein, nein, nicht nochmal starten, nicht nochmal
starten, ja, wie gesagt, also wenn ihr den check, also wenn ihr den linked in, das quiz
findet, dann gucken wir uns das zusammen an, aber es ist halt doof, dass dort die antwort
schon drin steht, ich will das ohne linked in account machen, paste bin, hi iq, ah, guck
mal, einfach rausgemacht, nice, sehr schön Leute, und jetzt mit dark reader noch, excellent,
excellent, nicht c, ach ne, der hat es einfach hier oben, ja, ok, das können wir uns dann
gleich mal angucken, wir basteln jetzt erstmal noch ein bisschen weiter, so, jetzt aktivieren
wir hier die checks, das mit dependency injection machen wir dann vielleicht, ich bin auch unschlüssig,
an welcher stelle ich das, an welcher stelle ich das brauche, so, also wir bekommen jetzt
alle Typen mit, die wir haben, so, dann enden wir das ganze, und jetzt müssen wir ja logischerweise
sagen, check, register, new, appconfig, so, appconfig gibt es, gibt es noch nicht wirklich,
das ist eine leere Klasse, so, dort kann der check dann beispielsweise sagen, er braucht
einen token, ein username, ein password und sowas, so, dann gucken wir, dann warten wir
bis ich die alle registriert habe, dann müssen wir irgendwie gucken, ob es Optionen, ich weiß
nicht genau, ob es Optionen für den check gibt, gibt es, also, was ich mir jetzt gerade
denke, ich bin mir gar nicht sicher, ob das überhaupt Sinn ergibt, ist, guck mal, wenn
ich das so aufrufe, zum Beispiel will ich das für Hetzner checken und für Namesylo
checken, aber ich habe ja beispielsweise auch ein Plugin für Namecheap, jetzt wird das Plugin
natürlich meckern, Achtung, mir fehlen Optionen, weil, naja, ohne Username ist es nicht lauffähig,
das Dumme ist bloß, wenn ich gar keine Optionen angegeben habe für dieses Plugin, dann möchte
ich dieses Plugin ja höchstwahrscheinlich auch gar nicht aufrufen, das heißt, damit
ich sowas umgehen kann, müsste ich eigentlich sowas hier machen, irgendwie, keine Ahnung,
wo weiters und dann irgendwie sowas wie, das ist aber auch doof, deswegen gucke ich lieber,
ob irgendeine Option gesetzt ist und wenn irgendeine Option gesetzt ist, dann gilt
das als, ich möchte es benutzen, ob das so funktioniert, ok, aber erstmal darf sich
der Kram so registrieren und dann adden wir den Check, ok, das passt soweit, das heißt,
an der Stelle sollte jetzt schon mal aus diesem Check das Register auf, oder du machst ein
extra Flag mit Ignore Provider für Flags, das musst du mir, das musst du mir mal genauer
erklären, was du, wenn ich jetzt so nix zusammenreime, was ein extra Flag mit, ok, also das wird
schon mal aufgerufen, das funktioniert, also das Plugin registriert sich, sagt hallo ich
bin da, so jetzt würde ich gerne sowas machen können wie, also was, machen wir es doch mal
ganz konkret am Beispiel, was braucht der Namecheap für Parameter, was brauchen die
denn für ihre API, so, oder nehmen wir mal, nehmen wir mal keine Ahnung, nehmen wir Name
Silo oder so, was brauchen die denn für eine API, die brauchen, oder du machst ein extra
Flag, ach so, ah, du meinst quasi so ein Help, sowas wie, es ist ein Aufruf mit minus
minus Help, dann ignorier ich den Error, das ist keine schlechte Idee, das werde ich mir
als mal Optionen mal aufschreiben, das finde ich eigentlich, denn das Plugin ist ja nicht
aktiviert, das soll ja eigentlich nur aktiviert sein, wenn es auch Optionen für hat, das heißt
im Endeffekt, ich würde jetzt gar nicht auf dem Plugin, in dem Fall, wenn es keine Optionen
gibt, würde ich jetzt gar nicht Init aufrufen, sondern nur Register, dann geht es einfach
nicht weiter, ich habe einen zweiten Monitor mit dem Chat, aber ich mache das immer auf,
dass ihr das seht, auf was ich mich gerade beziehe, so, und jetzt, genau, jetzt will
ich sowas hier machen, da bin ich mir jetzt auch noch unschlüssig, unschlüssig, was
ich jetzt gerne machen würde, ist sowas hier, AppConfig, also AppConfig soll quasi das
abstrahieren, woher die Optionen kommen, also das Plugin soll einmal sagen können, was
es für Optionen braucht, ja, zum Beispiel, das wollte ich ja gerade sagen, mal ganz konkret,
sagen wir mal hier, Available Operations, Domains, Get Domain Info, sowas, was braucht
Get Domain Info für Optionen, das braucht einen API Key, ok, wir brauchen dann zwei
Sachen, wir brauchen List Domains, Get Domain Info, ok, wir brauchen einen API Key, was
brauchen wir sonst, wir brauchen anscheinend nur einen API Key, so, API Key, das bedeutet
unser Plugin, damit das funktioniert, wobei, wir gucken jetzt mal mal den, was brauchen
die, API, Methods, Get Domains, Get Lists, so, also was brauchen die hier, die brauchen
einen API Key, ja, die brauchen einen API Key, also kann man quasi schon mal sowas
sagen, wie, wir brauchen Private Read Only, Private Read Only, wir brauchen Private String
Key und wir brauchen User, User und wir brauchen, ja, Client IP werden wir wahrscheinlich nicht
brauchen, so, also, sprich, damit dieses Plugin funktioniert, brauchen wir diese zwei
Optionen, so, und wenn ich das Programm jetzt aufrufe mit minus minus help, dann will ich
ja eine Hilferausgabe haben, wo drinnen steht, hey guck mal, diese Option kannst du alles
angeben, weil das weiß ja sonst keiner, das heißt, das Plugin muss einmal beim Registrieren
mitteilen können, was es für Optionen hat und dann muss es direkt danach, nachdem es
registriert hat, was es für Optionen haben kann oder zumindest mitgeteilt hat, was es
für Optionen möchte, muss man irgendwie auch diese Option quasi abfragen können, also
einmal brauchen wir das registrieren, damit es in der Hilfe auftaucht und gleichermaßen
muss der Kram natürlich ins Plugin irgendwie auch reinkommen, also was ich gerne machen
würde, wäre sowas hier, was wie app-config, get zum Beispiel und dann hier options, option
bla bla bla, so hier, option, string, also so würde ich das gerne, Moment, oder, doch,
get, option, string, ne, ist blödsinn was ich da hinschreibe, so, jetzt will ich ja gar
nicht Generic machen, get, sowas vielleicht, genau, hier, option, string, also ich möchte
eine Commando-Zeilen-Option haben, die heißt, user, mit description, login, account name,
zum Beispiel, so, und dafür will ich einmal einen Hilfeeintrag erzeugen und ich möchte
die Option, den Wert davon bekommen, also sowas hier in der Richtung würde ich jetzt
gerne machen, nur mit dem Unterschied, dass an der Stelle jetzt diese Option entweder
aus Environment-Variablen kommen kann, per Commando-Zeilen-Argumente kommen kann oder
aus einer config-Datei kommen kann, deswegen müssen wir das über app-config machen und
können hier nicht einfach sagen, Commando-Zeilen-Argumente parsen drinne, weil man weiß ja nicht woher
sie kommen, und von der Reihenfolge, da muss ich, chat, was ist eine sinnvolle Reihenfolge,
was überschreibt was, also ich würde sagen, Commando-Zeilen-Argumente zählen am meisten,
also wenn was als, also mal angenommen Hetzener-Trocken ist als Commando-Zeilen-Argument gesetzt,
dann sollte das Environment-Variablen und config-Datei überschreiben, also Commando-Zeilen-Parameter
sollten eigentlich immer die höchste Priorität haben, weil, überlegt mal, es könnte ja
sein, dass jemand sagt, ok, wir haben das allerdings auch als Environment-Variablen
gesetzt, und da steht jetzt 5, 6, 7, 8, und es gibt eine config-Datei, das heißt, was
soll jetzt gelten, soll jetzt die Environment-Variablen gelten, soll die config-Datei gelten oder
soll das Commando-Zeilen gelten, also ich würde auch sagen, ja, genau, chat, so sehe
ich das auch, so würde ich jetzt auch pauschal sagen, es gelten zuerst Commando-Zeilen-Argumente,
danach gelten Environment-Variablen, danach gelten Configs und danach gelten, tja, eventuelle
Default-Parameter oder sowas, falls es da welche gibt, oder halt gar nichts, das ist
halt nicht gesetzt, also so würde ich das jetzt gerne abfragen, App-Config-Get, New
Options, User Login Account Name, so in der Richtung, natürlich gibt es diese Methode
hier noch nicht, deswegen muss ich mir mal überlegen, wie wir das gescheit machen, ja,
ach so, ja, und was man bei der Gelegenheit auch machen könnte, ist, man könnte ja gleich
hier den Wert mitgeben, oder hier, dass man dann quasi sowas macht hier, das wäre doch
eigentlich ganz nett, wenn man das so aufrufen könnte, finde ich eigentlich nicht übel,
ich glaube, so könnte man das machen, wie man das jetzt natürlich mit System-Command-Line
bastelt, weiß ich nicht, müsste Config nicht über Enf stehen, oder habe ich einen Denkfehler,
kann man sich sicherlich darüber streiten, also so mein Bauchgefühl sagt mir, ich finde
die Reihenfolge auch sinnvoll, Kommando-Zeilen-Parameter, Environment und dann Config, aber man könnte
sicherlich auch sagen, man macht Kommando-Zeilen-Parameter, Config und danach gelten Environment-Variablen,
aber wahrscheinlich ist es, also ich kann jetzt nicht sagen, warum es gut, warum das
eine besser oder schlechter ist, aber so rein Bauchgefühl mäßig ist mir Kommando-Zeile,
Environment und dann Config irgendwie am natürlichsten, irgendwie so, Angular sackt gerade mega,
ja da gibt ihr übrigens auch Stack-Overflow recht, im letzten, nee nicht Stack-Overflow,
oder war das das Stack-Overflow-Umfrage oder war das die GitHub, nee GitHub-Umfrage war
das, oder Stack-Overflow, ich weiß, da hat Angular auch nicht gut abgeschnitten, ich
glaube 45% mögen es und 55% mögen es nicht, aber wie könnte man das hier, wie könnte
man das hier jetzt machen, also App-Config-Get, also Create-Method-App-Config-Get, dass wir
bekommen ne Option rein, CMD-Config-Enf, jetzt kann man sich darüber streiten, manche Leute
sagen im Chat auch, es soll CMD-Enf-Config sein, ich persönlich tendiere auch zu CMD-Enf-Config,
die Config-Datei will man in einem Docker-Container per Enf überschreiben, da hast du recht, ich
glaube, deswegen finde ich auch, ja gut, du musst ja gar keine Config-Datei hinlegen,
aber vielleicht hast du eine Default-Config-Datei und bei manchen Containern willst du es überschreiben,
du willst das Image nicht ändern, das könnte natürlich sein, du hast ein Container-Image
mit vielleicht irgendein Default-Config-Datei und bei manchen willst du es überschreiben,
ja vielleicht ist es doch wirklich am besten, wir sagen CMD-Env in einem Config, da kann
man sicherlich lange, lange Zeit drüber diskutieren, ne Parameter brauchen wir nicht, Parameter
gelten immer über allem, so wie können wir jetzt hier Sachen abfragen, also es muss
ich mal in mich gehen, ich habe System-Command-Line nicht oft verwendet, okay also get ist auf
jeden Fall Java-Generic, also T und nicht String, okay wie könnte das jetzt funktionieren
Leute, FIFAD-Time, FIFAD-Time, also System-Command-Line, System-Command-Line, Github, Domain-Champ,
ja weißt du, bei mir heißt alles Champ, Guide, Guide, Guide, Guide, Quickstart, System-Command-Line,
Setting-Started-Tutorial, ja genau, genau so, also Root-Command, also brauchen wir sowas
wie Root-Command gleich New Root-Commands, dann brauchen wir Add Sub-Commands, also mein
Commando-Zeilen-Tool soll Run und List haben, Listet alle unterstützten Provider auf, vielleicht
mit einem Beispiel dabei und was es für Optionen gibt und Run führt den Exporter aus, also
will ich auf jeden Fall schon mal den Command Run und ne, will ich das, ach seh, Moment,
ach ne, sowas brauch ich dann noch nicht, war irgendwie Run, Run-Command, Run, war List-Command,
New, war List, so, adden wir jetzt, Run-Command, List-Command und dann sagen wir am Ende glaube
ich einfach nur Execute, ne, Run, ne, was sagen wir, Invoke, ach die könnt ihr euch
auch nicht entscheiden wie der Kram heißt und dann, was, Invoke, ah die Commando-Zeilen-Argumente,
die über, so und wenn ich das jetzt ausführe, Run, Failed, warum, weil App, ah weil App-Config
kaputt ist, ja, Bam, Checker, jaja, Exception, alles gut, ok, aber prinzipiell funktioniert
das, ach ne, Moment, Return-Default-Of-T, will er da gar nichts machen, lasst, kann
ich String, darf theoretisch auch Null sein, ja wunderbar, Run, guck mal, funktioniert
schon, also die Hilferausgabe ist schon mal richtig, es gibt minusminus Help kann ich
machen, ach so, warum ich jetzt minusminus zweimal brauche ist, weil ich ruf das Programm
ja noch nicht mit dem eigenen Namen auf, sondern noch quasi über.net-Run, später ist es
dann.slash-domain-champ, aber jetzt muss ich erstmal sagen, die Optionen die danach
kommen gelten nicht für.net, sondern eben für mein eigenes Programm, und wenn man
in Bash minusminus macht, bedeutet ab minusminus kommen keine weiteren Optionen mehr, d.h.
wird alles durchgereicht und dann kann das weitere Programm, was aufgerufen wird, die
Optionen passen, ok, wir haben schon mal einen Hilfetext, der funktioniert, Commands-Run,
also wir haben ein Run-Command, ein List-Command, das ist schon mal gut, wir haben minusminus
Version, was kommt denn da raus, minusminus Version, 1.0, wusste ich auch noch nicht,
alles klar, und wir haben sowas wie minusminus-help, ja das ist doch schon mal nice, da weiß man
noch schon mal ungefähr, was man ausführen soll, gut, jetzt brauchen wir noch irgendeinen
Handler, ich, jetzt brauchen wir Run-Command, zhandmobile brauchen wir noch gar nicht, soweit
sind wir ja noch gar nicht, wir sind dabei, dass das Optionen registrieren soll, also
in Hilfe sollen ja nicht nur die Commands auftauchen, sondern in der Hilfe sollen jetzt
auch unter anderem auftauchen, minusminus-plugin-options, Darkseid, ich kann dir kurz erklären, was
wir machen, und zwar wir basteln einen Custom Prometheus-Exporter, der über die API von
verschiedenen Domain-Registrars das Expire-Datum für die ganzen Domains auslesen kann, sodass
man in seinem Monitoring ordentlich überwachen kann, wann seine Domains auslaufen, weil die
Tools, die es dafür gibt, die sind entweder auf Whois, also die gehen über Whois, was
Mist ist und bei vielen Domains nicht funktioniert, oder man muss irgendein komisches PHP-Tool
verwenden, was die meisten Anbieter nicht unterscheiden, und ich habe nichts gefunden,
ich würde es gar nicht selbst programmieren, wenn es was gäbe, ich habe nichts gefunden,
aber ich denke mir, das ist etwas, was nicht nur ich brauche, sondern viele gebrauchen
können, deswegen bauen wir mal was.
Warum da vorher nicht jemand drauf gekommen ist, es gibt solche Exporter, aber die sind,
guck mal hier, Exporter-Domain, aber die basieren auf Whois und das ist doof, oh die haben auch
157 Sterne, aber das ist doof, du musst erstens die Domain direkt angeben und sie basieren
auf Whois, was nicht funktioniert, du nutzt Home Assistant zum Monitorn von Domains, ok,
wie kriegst du, das würde mich jetzt tatsächlich interessieren, wie kriegst du in Home Assistant
raus, wann deine Domain abläuft, gar nicht, wie willst du es machen, also das würde mich
jetzt echt interessieren, du kriegst in Home Assistant rein, wann Zertifikate ablaufen,
weil du abfragen kannst, wann das expired, ja das ist kein Ding, genau das geht nicht,
das ist das, das ist das, was ich aber haben will, also unser Plugin muss sich jetzt registrieren
mit seiner Option, wie können wir das machen, also AppConfig get, AppConfig get, ok also
AppConfig braucht schon mal, damit das Ganze funktioniert, braucht AppConfig schon mal
die Kommandozeilen Argumente, dass es rausparsen kann, was es, was übergeben wurde, also sprich
welche Kommandozeilen Argumente übergeben, sonst funktioniert das schon mal nicht, also
die Kommandozeilen Argumente brauchste, dann braucht es wahrscheinlich das Command, wofür
die Option ist, dann braucht es irgendwie so eine Art Prefix, weil es könnte ja sein,
das ist mir nämlich gerade eben eingefallen, wo ich in Chat geguckt habe, Whois bringt
dir nichts, Whois hat nicht die Information bei den meisten Domains, ja es könnte ja
sein, dass mehrere, guck mal was macht man, wenn mehrere Plugins sowas wie Key und User
haben wollen, das heißt man muss das irgendwie Prefixen, damit es dann heißt Hetzner User
oder Namecheap User und nicht einfach nur User, also wir brauchen so eine Art Prefix
und dann irgendwie das Config File, falls es sowas gibt, ey Maxi, ich verfolge dich schon
auf YouTube schon seit einigen Jahren, schreib dir das erste Mal, ja ich sehe auch, First
Time Chatter, ich bin total verzweifelt, meine Arbeitskollegen machen größtenteils
nur Dienst nach Vorschrift, ja das ist bei vielen leider so, da ist aber oftmals auch
der Arbeitgeber zum größten Teil mit dran schuld, weil er eben nicht schafft den Leuten
Perspektiven zu bieten oder aber zu komplett falsche Anreize setzt, so nach dem Motto,
ja wir sollen super innovativ und agil und sowieso sein, aber jedes Mal wenn du innovativ
und agil bist, kriegst du einen Anschluss, dann haben die Leute auch keinen Bock mehr,
ich hingegen bin eher ärgert sicher, wahrscheinlich weil du noch nicht so lange dabei bist und
die anderen schon keinen Bock mehr haben, du willst nicht nur rumpimmeln, aus dem Grund
werde ich von diesen Kollegen, hast du, ja, also je nachdem, ich weiß ja nicht in welchem
Ausmaß das ist, aber du hast immer die Möglichkeit, wenn du nicht zu deinem Chef gehen willst,
zum Betriebsrat zu gehen, wenn sowas ist, also wenn gar nichts geht, kannst du zum Betriebsrat
gehen, kannst natürlich auch mit deinem Chef reden oder naja, je nachdem wie die Leute
drauf sind, ist das manchen vielleicht auch gar nicht so klar, dass sie mit blöden Sprüchen
hier wirklich auf den Sack gehen, aber es gibt natürlich auch Leute, ich kenne die ja
nicht, ich kenne die ja nicht, es gibt natürlich auch Leute, die gehen dir dann erst recht
auf den Sack, aber das ist ja kein Arbeitsumfeld, ganz im Ernst, wenn du wirklich sagst, du
bist ehrgeizig und in dem Laden klappt das nicht, hast du schonmal dran gedacht dir einfach
einen besseren Arbeitgeber zu suchen, weil dein Chef scheint es ja nicht auf die Reihe
zu kriegen, Betriebsrat habt ihr nicht, wenn du ehrgeizig bist und Ahnung hast, vielleicht
bist du bei einem anderen Arbeitgeber besser aufgehoben, es ist natürlich blöd, weil man
dann im Hinterkopf hat so nach dem Motto, oh man hat den Schwanz eingezogen oder sowas,
also würde ich es gar nicht mal sehen, man muss sich doch nicht auf Teufel komm raus
mit nervigen Leuten, mit irgendwelchen Kackspasten auseinandersetzen, sondern kann einfach sagen,
macht euren Scheiß alleine und gerade wenn es der Chef nicht auf die Reihe kriegt, der
ja nur wirklich dafür da ist, ich meine, wenn dir ein Job gefällt, es gibt ja vielleicht
auch die Möglichkeit, dass du in eine andere Abteilung gehst, ich weiß ja nicht wie groß
der Laden ist, allzu groß wird er wahrscheinlich nicht sein, wenn er kein Betriebsrat hat,
das ist
immer weit.
ein paar sachen ich habe ungern nicht recht geht aber glaube ich jedem so gerade wenn es um
technische sachen geht und wirklich mir jemand beweisen kann ich habe miss erzählt das mache
habe ich nicht gerne aber letztendlich kann man es nicht vermeiden jeder erzählt mal miss
das habe ich nicht gerne und ich gebe ungern klein bei so nach dem motto irgendwas was mir auf den
sack geht kann ich nur dadurch dadurch beheben dass ich eben ignoriere oder abhau aber letztendlich
ganz im ernst das die letzten paar jahre hat sich das hat sich ein bisschen gebessert man ist nicht
auf der arbeit um die leute zu erziehen und ja man ist auch nicht da um dich zu erziehen vielleicht
als azubi noch ein bisschen und wenn es da so gravierende unterschiede gibt zwischen dem wie
du dir eine gute gute arbeitsatmosphäre vorstellst und wie sich das unternehmen beziehungsweise deine
kollegen eine gute arbeitsatmosphäre vorstellen und du sogar mit einem chef da schon öfters
darüber gesprochen hast und sich überhaupt nichts tut was willst du machen du kannst zum
betriebsrat dem es nicht gibt du kannst zur personalabteilung theoretisch falls sie das
interessiert wobei man halt sagen muss die personalabteilung ist in der regel nicht die
vertretung für mitarbeiter sondern von der geschäftsführung also die personalabteilung
ist eher auf seite der firma als auf deiner seite also wenn es schon wirklich bei dir diese
ausmaße annimmt dass du dass du dass es dir dadurch so schlecht geht dass du nicht auf die
arbeit auf die arbeit ich glaube nicht dass er in dem zustand noch bock hat sich mit kunden
als betriebsrat auseinanderzusetzen an bord brauchst du harte nerven ja ohne scheiß wenn
du sagst du bist ehrgeizig und der laden an sich scheint ja kacke zu sein wenn selbst du sagst die
arbeit gefällt dir aber überleg mal das was du machst ja da siehst du doch dass der laden vom
ansatz her schon mal kacke ist und ich sag dir du findest bei anderen firmen wenn du ahnung
hast und ehrgeizig es gibt ja durchaus selten diese kombination leute ganz im ernst ahnung
plus ehrgeizig ist selten es gibt es gibt vier verschiedene arten von leuten es gibt die also
können wir ja paint paint ne komm wir sind mal wir benutzen mal wir benutzen mal was anderes
was was es gibt ja alter dark mode please hat es dark mode alles in dark mode heute ich brauche
dark mode hier dark mode nice alles klar ok ich würde ich würde gerne ich würde gerne was
malen so also du hast ja du hast im prinzip vier vier vier arten von leuten benutzt man den
krempel überhaupt war ich ein strich ich will strich machen das exzellent exzellent strich
hast du hast vier arten von leuten also du hast sagen wir mal leute
war hier die schriftfarbe also was leute mit ahnung das hier und du hast leute die sind
ehrgeizig hat man das überhaupt so immer sogar google sogar google hat kein bock ja schreibt
man so also du hast leute die haben ahnung und du hast leute die sind ehrgeizig so diese zwei
sachen jetzt hast ja vier verschiedene jetzt hast ja vier verschiedene kombinationen also ich muss
das so machen was leute mit ahnung du hast leute die sind ehrgeizig das ergibt natürlich vier
fälle so hier hast du ein hier hast du welche die haben keine oder sag was alles hier hast du
welche die haben ahnung uns sind ehrgeizig also die sind quasi doppelt die haben die haben doppelt
x oder sowas haben wir hier hast du leute die haben das ein und das andere nicht und umgedreht
ihr könnt ihr könnt euch vorstellen ich muss das wahrscheinlich muss das wahrscheinlich gar nicht
mal gar nicht malen und ja das gibt wirklich das aber dienst nach vorschrift kann man so machen so
machen wir das erfüllen nicht doppelte erfüllen keine ahnung keine ahnung so so ergibt jetzt
jetzt jetzt jetzt jetzt passt das so was leute sind ehrgeizig das leute die haben keine ahnung
oder die machen dienst nach vorschrift so daraus ergibt sich ja dann so kombination gibt es dann
ja sowas sowas gibt es dann da ja so diese diese diese kombination hast du im ende an leuten so
und ich glaube jetzt ich glaube jetzt kann man es ungefähr jetzt kann man es ungefähr erkennen
so und du scheinst ja in diese kategorie zu fallen und da sieht man schon das ist ja quasi
nur einer von vier möglichkeiten und diese leute sind tatsächlich selten also es gibt
wenig leute die ahnung haben plus ehrgeizig sind es gibt durchaus leute die keine ahnung
haben und ehrgeizig sind das ist übrigens eine ganz schlechte kombination keine ahnung und
ehrgeizig keine ahnung und ehrgeizig bedeutet die machen ihr quasi alles kaputt das ist das
ist schlecht also das ist wirklich doof die kombination keine ahnung und dienst nach vorschrift
ist ok die sind halt anwesend machen aber nichts kaputt und dann gibt es ahnung und dienst nach
vorschrift ich würde sagen die meisten leute fallen irgendwie so in diese kategorien und
manchmal manchmal gibt es auch noch die aber die hier musst du dir wirklich aus firmen sicht warm
halten ja leute die wirklich tatendrang haben und ahnung haben und wenn du jemand bist und
dass das worauf ich raus will wenn du jemand bist der ahnung hat und tatendrang hat ich nehme sie
überall du hast ahnung und du machst auch was das will jede firma haben lange rede kürzer sind das
wollte ich eigentlich sagen damit dienst nach vorschrift war jetzt nur weil er es geschrieben
hat man könnte es auch faul nennen nennen was nennen was faul ja weil dann würde ich eindeutig
auch in diese kategorie fallen wir nennen es einfach wir nennen es einfach faul ja es ist
nicht dienst anwesend faul ich laufe aber faul mit ahnung so in der richtung das leute sind
super ehrgeizig so und ich ich würde ich würde mich selbst will ich es ist immer eigenlob stink
ich selbst würde mich eher in diese in diese kategorie einkopieren auch mal hänni klingelt
der fack ich würde mich eher in diese kategorie ich kenne mich in manchen gebieten schon ganz gut
aus aber ich bin faul das fack es sei denn es interessiert mich da gebe ich keine ruhe das hat
aber auch seinen vorteil denn leute die ahnung haben und faul sind die machen die sachen meistens
richtig weil sie sich nie wieder damit beschäftigen wollen also besser einmal gescheit gemacht als
50 mal nicht richtig wenn ihr natürlich ahnung habt und ehrgeizig seid ist das natürlich doppelt
doppelt gut für doppelt es ist doppelt gut für euch ja übrigens ist das hier tatsächlich
auch für führungskräfte gar nicht so schlecht keine ahnung und faul weil leute die keine ahnung
und faul haben hören auf leute die ahnung haben hoffentlich und können gut sachen delegieren leute
die faul sind können generell gut sachen delegieren aber leute die ahnung haben und faul sind lassen
ungern leute andere leute was machen weil sie jeder meinung sind sie sind die eins in die plan
das hier sind tatsächlich würde ich mal sagen sogar ganz gute führungskräfte allerdings die
hier kannst du für nix gebrauchen also keine ahnung und ehrgeizig kannst du komplett vergessen
diese leute so das ist das was ich eigentlich sagen wollte warum auch immer ich da dieses
glia krampel gebraucht hat ja das ist schön und gut wenn die leute also es ist nachvollziehbar
wenn die leute dienst nach vorschrift machen und kein bock haben meinetwegen kann an der firma
liegen aber sie sollten dich nicht abfacken weil du was machen willst sie selbst können ja machen
was sie wollen aber sie sollen dich nicht quasi sie sollen dir das umfeld nicht so zur hölle
machen weil sie selbst kein bock haben dass du nicht mehr auf die arbeit kommen willst und ganz
ehrlich dein chef scheint mir in der form auch nicht sonderlich fähig zu sein wenn er quasi
am horizont auftauchen sieht schon du machst dich vom acker wegen den anderen kollegen obwohl es
eigentlich hauptsächlich daran liegt weil du mehr arbeiten willst und es kriegt er nicht auf die
reihe dann ist da kannst du den laden vergessen also ganz im ernst du hast ahnung du bist
ehrgeizig du findest easy was neues die nehmen dich alle mit mit verbeugung quasi die sagen alle
kommt zu uns und du kriegst bei allen anderen mindestens das was du jetzt kriegst mit gehaltserhöhung
plus noch was obendrauf also was du jetzt bekommst seit der gehaltserhöhung plus was obendrauf
kann du dankeschön was ein gutes einstiegs galt für die anwendung sind wir gar keine ahnung aber
ganz im ernst so unter 40k ist es heutzutage schon ein bisschen bisschen orschwenig anzufangen also
mein einstiegsgehalt damals beim provider war 33.500 richtig deswegen du hast jetzt eine richtig
gute position was noch ein arbeitsvertrag du kannst ohne probleme nicht umgucken und je nachdem
wie du drauf bist kannst du es auf deinem kannst du es auf deinem chef stecken dass du dich umguckst
aber du kannst dich umgucken weil du hast keinerlei zeitdruck und du kannst dir wirklich das beste
rausholen ich sagte wenn du wirklich ahnung hast und ehrgeizig bist die nehmen dich alle die sind
happy wenn sie jemand finden der plan hat und wenn es einer ist der plan hat und auch noch tatsächlich
was arbeiten will das würde ich auf jeden fall machen ich habe einen trick gehört von einem
unserer konsultanz tatsächlich einer der wenigen konsultanz bei uns auf der arbeit es ist es ist
wirklich so also die an die kannst du alle vergessen das ist einer der wenigen konsultanz
bei uns auf der arbeit wo ich sagen würde gar nicht gar nicht so schlecht ja das stimmt wenn du
den profil anlegst dann kriegst du am tag oder kriegst du in der woche 30 sinnlose anfragen vielleicht
auch was gescheites also ein trick ist wenn du ein arbeitszeugnis haben willst du willst ja kein
arbeitszeugnis haben in form von abschluss und du gehst jetzt du willst ein zwischenzeugnis haben
aber du hättest gerne schon ein so wie das qualifiziert ist ein ordentliches ein ordentliches
zwischenzeugnis wurde dann im zweifelsfall auch mit schicken könntest bei der bewerbung so und
normalerweise drücken sich der arbeitgeber ganz gerne vor die sagen ja wie zwischenzeugnis es
gibt doch eigentlich nichts gibt auch keinen anlass dazu dass es in zwischenzeugnis gibt und
normalerweise ist es auch so die müssen ihr kein zwischenzeugnis ausstellen wenn es kein anlass
gibt ein anlass ist zum beispiel ein führungskräftewechsel aber ich vermute mal du
hattest keinen führungskräftewechsel und einer unserer konsultanz hat mir einen trick verraten
wie man nahezu immer ein arbeitszeugnis bekommt auch ohne führungskräftewechsel und so was und
zwar man muss sagen man möchte ein arbeitszeugnis haben weil sich der aufgabenbereich geändert hat
das kann man immer sagen und es scheint wohl auch rechtlich unglaublich schwierig zu sein für
arbeitgeber das quasi aus diesem grund abzulehnen weil dann müssten ja quasi sagen es gab keinen
wechsel oder sagst dann müssen die irgendwie sich aus den fingern sagen wie aufgaben wurden
nicht gewechselt du kannst das aber sagen dann müssen die sich erst mal überlegen ok vielleicht
ist da was und es kann ja durchaus sein dass sich deine aufgaben gewechselt haben
du kannst immer ein zeugnis verlangen sie müssen es aber nicht machen du kannst es doch
einfach sagen kannst auch einfach sagen mein aufgabengebiet hat sich gewechselt mein aufgabengebiet
hat sich erweitert du sagst du musst nicht sagen aufgabengebiet hat sich gewechselt hat sich geändert
dass dein aufgabengebiet hat sich erweitert und garantiert hat sich dein aufgabengebiet erweitert
die letzten monate über it ist so schnell ewig der ändert sich doch laufen was also ich habe
kein zwischenzeugnis für meine bewerbung gebraucht ich habe mein zwischenzeugnis aber mitgeschickt
ich habe es euch ja im stream schon mal vorgelesen sagt ein aufgabengebiet hat sich erweitert
geänderte aufgaben du willst ein zwischenzeugnis da können die ganz schwer ich glaube das einfach
mal unserem consultant dude ganz schwer was gegen machen so leute jetzt haben wir bisschen
den faden verloren wo sind wir dann stehen geblieben warum kompiliert das ganze nicht
achso hier ok also wir möchten jetzt aus unseren plugins da sind wir eigentlich stehen geblieben
wir möchten jetzt unseren plugins optionen von der kommando zeile einlesen und wollen
dass das ganze im hilfetext auftaucht ok lass mal überlegen command haben wir weisen wir
mal zu prefix weisen wir mal zu args weisen wir mal zu jetzt müssen wir hier irgendwie
gucken wie wir das wie wir das rausbekommen also
ja wie gesagt ich habe auch mein zeugnis nicht mitgeschickt ich habe auch nur skills
und lebenslauf geschickt aber ich habe dann gesagt ich kann euch noch zusätzlichen zeugnis
hochladen nachdem ich mein vorstellungsgespräch dort hatte und wir uns schon einig waren
nachträglich hätte ich auch hätte ich auch nicht gebraucht ok wie kriege ich an der stelle
jetzt diese options ok das erste was ich machen kann ist schon mal relativ einfach ich kann
sagen cmd add option option so wenn ich das gemacht habe achso nee ich muss erst mal
den kram noch übergeben new app config args run command oder
run command ja doch nur für run so und prefix den name will ich haben ok jetzt sollte eigentlich
das plugin eine hilfeausgabe liefern fuck ach nee ich muss wahrscheinlich run help machen
oder hey geht guck mal plugin hat eine hilfeausgabe user login account name nice so ja genau so
will ich das genauso genauso gefällt mir das so muss das sein so jetzt will ich allerdings
dass die option nicht minus minus user heißt weil user könnte es ja für mehrere anbieter
geben ich lese ich lese mir gleich gleich die sachen durch mich will er dass es für
mehrere sagen es möglich ist ein user anzulegen deswegen muss da noch ein prefix davor also
haben wir sowas mal wie name option name option doch brauchen wir brauchen wir doch option
name weil das ändern wir jetzt zwar ändern wir das in minus minus wollen wir haben wollen
wir nicht einfach user haben wir wollten minus also wir wollen die linux style moin max du
bist gerade bei stay live mit im video ok also was wie kommts also was ist da warum
also in die it runde gefragt schickt ihr noch anschreiben mit nee habe ich nicht gemacht
ach so nicht das stream ok zeig mal nicht das stream sondern mein video oder was hier
bin ich live hey alles ok aber ich kann euch gar nicht auf die emails alle gucke ich mir
nachher an gucke ich gucke ich mir nachher an stabiles video ja so sieht es aus lustig
es wird quasi oder kann ich da kann ich endlich mal reacten auf eine reaction reaction
ok warte kurz hier so also was was wollte ich jetzt hier aber so in die it runde gefragt
schickt ihr noch anschreiben mit ich schreibe es ich schreibe es tatsächlich noch weil
mir das auch ein bisschen spaß macht aber eigentlich reichen viel oder ja weil man mir
auch so ich habe kein anschreiben hingeschrieben also weder dort wo es jetzt was geworden ist
noch bei denen in würzburg aber gut ich kannte da auch schon leute ich habe kein anschreiben
gebraucht weiter weiter im text jetzt bin ich jetzt bin ich jetzt habt ihr mich
abgelenkt jetzt weiß ich gar nicht wo ich wo ich dann geschehen für den zapp man kommt
was zum gehalt das kommt dann auch wenn das auto review kommt oder wenn ich das video
mit dem florian aufgenommen habe oder wenn ich also ich habe noch so viele offene sachen
ich muss das auch ein paar andere sachen abarbeiten außerdem so wirklich sinnvoll ist das video
wahrscheinlich erst in einem jahr wenn ich wirklich weiß was unterm strich rauskommt
aber gut ich werde euch nicht ich werde euch nicht ein jahr darauf warten lassen wahrscheinlich
in in nächster zeit ich kann sie nicht ich weiß wurde mir gerade schon geschrieben wurde
mir gerade schon geschrieben ich gucke mir das nachher in ruhe an ich muss jetzt keine
reacception starten dass wir reaktieren auf jemand der auf mich reaktiert noch besser
wäre es gewesen wenn ich reaktiert hätte er mein video wo ich reaktiert hätte gucke
und jetzt darauf reakte das ist ja mittlerweile im influencer game überhaupt kein ding mehr
da wird da wird fünffach reaktiert ich habe teilweise videos gesehen leute auf youtube
die mir empfohlen werden da hast du echt gedacht was war was geht da ab in scope reaktiert
auf irgendwie in scope reaktiert auf unge oder was weiß ich auf knossi reaktiert wird
oder zwischenzeitlich noch montana black reaktiert und so was du hast fünf webcams übereinander
weil der jede auf jeden im kreis reaktiert und dann zwei zwei wochen später kommt nächstes
video weil zwei leute davon jetzt irgendwie beef haben und er reaktiert dann noch mal
auf die reaction der reaction von dem anderen um noch eine woche später darauf zu reaktieren
das ist mittlerweile auf youtube rasten die da alle komplett aus ich gucke mir das nachher
an wir machen jetzt keine live reaction auf die reaction aber ja zum thema gehalt sage
ich was sage ich was in nächster zeit ich kann sie nicht genau sagen was was und wann
also wie viel es ist habe ich jetzt oft genug im stream schon gesagt so grob aber im video
muss ich mir mal überlegen okay so jetzt muss ich endlich weiter basteln ein bisschen
was was brauchbares bei rauskommt also wir wollen nicht minus minus user wir wollen
unsere kommando zeilen argumenten drinne stehen haben prefix wenn ich das richtig richtig mir
so denke prefix und dann anderskoor anderskoor nein wenn ich das jetzt richtig gemacht habe
steht jetzt auch was sinnvolles in der ausgabe drin funktioniert komm mal ja was ist das wir
haben den plug-in was auto was was kommando zeilen argumenten registrieren kann das ist
nice das gefällt mir options wir können auch die hilfe setzen hilf wird einfach name und
gut ist was es wird kann ich dir erklären hast du bin so weit mit dem chat hinten dran ich muss
mal kurz überlesen du klingst wie stefan rab ihr werdet lachen das haben tatsächlich
schon mehr leute gesagt früher wo ich konnte auf duty videos gemacht haben das oft gerade wenn
ich über irgendwas gelacht haben ganz ganz viele leute damals geschrieben es klingt wie stefan
rab also ist ich da ist ich das eine der einzige der das ich bin ich weiß ich also mir wäre es so
jetzt nicht aufgefallen man hört ja seine eigene stimme eh nicht gerne leck hd dankeschön für den
sub was machst du mit dem ganzen geld wahrscheinlich das gleiche was ich mit dem geld jetzt auch schon
mache nicht ausgeben also unsere plugins können kommando zeilen argumenten registrieren das ist
schon mal gut das heißt ich kann jetzt so returnen müsste ich das ganze natürlich auch noch
kann die fold sondern return ja was denn jetzt options und get das ich habe mir das im vorfall
ok wenn das jetzt alles funktioniert dann sollte ich jetzt ein kommando zeilen parameter
angeben können für mein plugin also gucken wir mal was hat er denn hier für schmerzen eigentlich
jetzt sollte ich dann den user rauskriegen jetzt bin ich mal gespannt jetzt bin ich mal gespannt ob das funktioniert guck mal hier
cool das heißt wir können das ist das ist das geht das ging jetzt einfacher als ich mir das
vorgestellt habe das heißt wir kriegen jetzt in unsere plugins alle möglichen parameter rein die
wir brauchen das schon mal praktisch was ist tatsächlich das viel einfacher als gedacht
habe also kommando zeilen parameter bis jetzt jetzt kommen wir noch konfig feil konfig feil
und environment variablen warum kennst du dich so gut mit objektorientierung aus wenn du noch
bisher der von engineer fast oder hast du bei der bank als programmieren wieder noch ich habe ich
habe nie hauptberuflich als anwendungsentwickler gearbeitet das habe ich ja immer hier disclaimer
bei den steams ich habe nie hauptberuflich als anwendungsentwickler gearbeitet ich
programmiere aber gerne schon seit wenn ich 2000 noch was rum ich habe angefangen damals mit
python 2.3 oder so danach relativ kurz ich bin gar nicht sicher was zuerst was könnte auch zuerst
dort nett gewesen sein danach sie schaab da war sie schaab 2 nee es war zuerst python 2 3 und
danach war sie schaab da war gerade dort nett 2 raus mit generics aber die tutorials die ich
gesehen habe war noch teilweise dort nett 11 op ist ein buch mit sieben siegel ist in der heutigen
zeit auch nicht mehr so mega im trend heute ist es eher composition nicht so sehr objektorientierung
aber im ernst zu die basics sind sind objektorientierung noch gar nicht so schwierig zu
verstehen also wo wo wo hängst du wo hängst denn was ist composition dass du jetzt keine klasse
dass ok ich versuche mal ich versuche mal ein beispiel zu machen ja bei bei objektorientierung
würdest du denn eine klasse anlegen die heißt bus und die erbt von vehikel oder so was das
wäre so objektorientierung so und dann hast du dann in in vehikel hast du so sachen definiert
wie hupen fahren sonst sonst was und gut ja interface weil diese sprachen meistens keine
klassen in dem sinn haben go hat er zum beispiel auch keine klassen go hat interfaces die etwas
angereichert werden können mit objektorientierung aber du könntest ja zum beispiel anstatt eine
autoklasse zu bauen die von vehikel erbt ne ne ne ne ne das sind unterschiedliche paar schuhe
du könntest ja zum beispiel auch ein objekt aus thailand zusammensetzen du könntest ja auch zum
beispiel so was machen wie anstatt in new bus zu sagen würdest du zum beispiel sagen ein bus
setzt sich zusammen aus create create vehikel add door add sonst was set size und so was in
der richtung und dann hast du dann im endeffekt ein vehikel was aber die eigenschaften von einem
bus hat ohne dass es eine fertige klasse gibt die bus heißt also du baust dir dann quasi aus
den bestandteilen eher deine objekte zusammen meistens sind es dementsprechend auch interfaces
wie in go die du dann ein bisschen anreichern kannst mit extra metoden aber vieles ist in go
wenn man in richtung objektorientierung was probiert eklig als beispielsweise noch nicht
mal einen constructor oder so was gibt also du kannst in go nicht sagen ok wenn du jetzt eine
instanz anlegen willst ich bin übrigens gar nicht sicher ob die das in go so nennen wenn zum
beispiel eine instanz anlegen willst von irgendeinem interface da kannst du keinen constructor dann
musst du sowas irgendwie wie new machen und bei new hast du wieder das problem dass du dann alles
spezifizieren musst was dieses was dieser typ was dieser typ braucht auch wenn es vielleicht gar
nicht sinnvoll ist es sind einfach unterschiedliche paar ansätze kannst du noch mal interfaces in
c sharp erklären interfaces ist quasi sowas wie ein vertrag ich glaube ich glaube ich glaube im
englischen sagen sie auch zu interfaces immer contract interfaces ist sowas wie ein vertrag
im interface definiert was muss ein spät bestimmter typ erfüllen damit du ihn quasi benutzen kannst
wie in diesem interface definiert wohingegen eine klasse ein konkreter typ ist ist ein interface
immer abstrakt ein interface definiert nur was implementiert werden muss wenn man das verstehe
das ist doch ein gutes beispiel ja wenn interface ja mein interface i domain check in diesem
interface ist nichts implementiert dieses interface besagt einfach nur wenn irgendein typ dieses
interface implementiert dann muss er sich erstellen dass er eine dass er ein property description
hat ein property ein property interval eine metode register eine metode in eine metode ran
das heißt du kannst jetzt eine klasse erstellen und sagen ich möchte hier ganz ganz glas blub ich
will eine klasse erstellen die kompatibel ist zu diesem interface man sagt also das implementiert
das interface also ich will quasi eine klasse ist ein konkreten typ wie man da so schön sagt will
ich erstellen der kompatibel zu diesem interface ist damit das so ist muss ich alles anlegen in
meiner upps in meiner klasse was das interface alter was das interface definiert also damit
das ein gültiges i domain check ist die klasse blub muss ich alles das was das interface fordert
in meiner klasse implementieren bei vererbung würde das ganze anders aussehen bei vererbung
müsste ich so prinzipiell erst mal gar nichts zusätzlich implementieren es sei denn die
feldas sind abstrakt das bietet sich zum beispiel an plugins wenn du zum beispiel plugins verwenden
willst in deinem programm dann sagst du ok jeder typ der dieses interface implementiert
hat den kann ich als plugin verwenden es ist schwierig so aus dem stegreif zu erklären ist
gar nicht so einfach manche es hat alles seine daseinsberechtigung im bereich machine learning
macht zu heißen nix vor dank ist die schaap so ein bisschen ein bisschen stiefmütterlich
behandelt andere sachen ist in dort nett deutlich angenehmer einfach für die es hat
überhaupt keinen sinn sich über programmiersprachen zu streiten was besser ist außer dass rast
das beste ist wenn du hacker news fragst und wenn du mich fragst hier plus plus das schlimmste was
es gibt es hat fast alles seine daseinsberechtigung würdet ihr als würdet ihr sie schaap als gute
sprache zum kann man machen die beste objekt orientierte programmiersprache ist ruby finde
ich ruby ist super aber ruby ist leider durch das verfall der ruby on rails beliebtheit
bisschen ins hintertreffen geraten also ist pyson wahrscheinlich gar nicht verkehrt wobei
ich echt nicht weiß wie gut das mit objektorientierung in pyson ist da gibt es
ein paar sachen die mich verwirrt haben so als jemand der nicht so viel damit macht
du hast so ein paar magic du hast so paar magic methods sowas wie die keys und sowas wo man
nicht so genau weiß wo die herkommen ein paar sachen habe ich da habe ich da in pyson
objektorientierung ein bisschen verwirrt aber an sich war es relativ straightforward also
kann man machen also go ist auf jeden fall nicht das richtige wenn man objektorientierung lernen
will also ich persönlich mag sie schaap aber pyson geht wahrscheinlich genauso gut oder
java meinetwegen auch nicht verkehrt es heißt übrigens wenn man wenn wir jetzt mal super
korrekt sind müsstest du schreiben ich kann auch keine instanz der klasse xy anlegen das wäre dann
der fall wenn man über korrekt sein will müsste man das so sagen ja also ich kann auch keine
instanz der klasse xy anlegen ohne dass ich die geforderten werte die in der klasse definition
stehen naja wenn du meinst jetzt deine klasse das interface implementier du kannst auch nicht
mal kompilieren du kannst auch nicht mal kompilieren ohne dass deine klasse das das anlegt guck mal
wenn ich jetzt sage hier public class kackel ein domain check und ich versuche das jetzt zu
kompilieren dann sagt er beim geht nicht kackel das nord implement interface member so natürlich
könnte ich das dynamisch nachladen und das irgendwo anders herholen dann würde mir wahrscheinlich zur
runtime sagen dass die methode schlicht und klein nicht da ist aber das geht nicht richtig also du
musst alles was das interface definiert hier implementieren dass es eben gültig kompatibel
zu diesem interfaces dir fällt vielleicht darauf dass es kein public und sowas gibt hier drin muss
es nicht geben weil alles was in einem interface implementiert ist ist public alles was in einem
interface definiert ist ist public und muss implementiert werden das ist der sinn von einem
interface also quasi ein eine schrittstelle bereitzustellen also alles was diese schrittstelle
dieses interface implementiert ist kompatibel dazu nicht ganz verwenden es gibt es gibt in
sie schafft noch ein paar feinheiten zwischen classes und interfaces zum beispiel zum beispiel
bei generics kannst du mehrere interfaces angeben als bedingungen nur eine klasse und sowas
muss also ein bisschen das feeling für kriegen manchmal ist sind sind base classes gut manchmal
sind interfaces gut und seitdem nur interfaces mittlerweile auch die fault implementierung machen
kannst auch so ein ding wo man sich fragt ob das so eine gute idee war verschwimmen die grenzen da
noch mehr ich würde sagen man braucht man braucht auf jeden fall beides in letzten jahren sind
interfaces so beliebt geworden dass sie fast base klassen so ein bisschen den rank abgelaufen
haben also es gibt heutzutage viel mehr die verwehr viel mehr verwendung von interfaces als
noch früher man hat schon immer beides verwendet aber früher waren abstrakte base classes und
sowas mehr verbreitet heute sind interface ein bisschen beliebter sein aber auch für den
anwendungsfall ab muss ich beides angucken also spätestens wenn du irgendwelche libraries
verwendest dann kannst du eigentlich davon ausgehen dort werden immer interfaces übergeben wenn es
was konkretes also wenn es was sein muss was kein base typ ist oder so der in der standard library
ist dann werde ich in der regel mittlerweile immer interfaces übergeben oder aber halt direkt eine
klasse wenn es halt nur ein typ davon geben kann ich muss ich kein interface machen von
einem typ wenn es davon immer nur einen geben soll wie hast du eigentlich dann windows denung
switch gemacht nee einfach virtuelle windows desktops verwendet guck da blub blub blub blub blub blub blub
dreht er durch hier nice also und jetzt mal wieder eigentlich in sache weiter zu machen also
halbe stunde basteln werden auch ein bisschen weiter wir haben ja schon ganz gut was gemacht
also wir können jetzt optionen übergeben und wir bekommen sogar ein hilfetext für plugins
das ist doch schon mal nice so was jetzt allerdings noch fehlt ist und das dürfte
ein bisschen komplizierter werden also records in c-sharp sind tatsächlich ganz sinnvoll
man braucht sie nicht oft ja aber sind teilweise ganz ganz nützlich moment also ihr seht jetzt
ich kann jetzt schon mal name cheap plugin domain check auf auf namcheap kann ich schon
mal in user per kommando zeile über die sache ist jetzt die ich will nicht nur ein user übergeben
per kommando zeile sondern ich möchte das ganze auch aus config dateien und aus umgebungsvariablen
übergeben können das heißt wir machen jetzt mal folgendes wir legen jetzt noch zwei weitere
sachen an nämlich einmal user einmal password und einmal das ist irgendwas irgendwas irgendwas
anderes aber hier einmal man int um das zu testen und auch und hier auch einen auch einen int und
das hier ist kackel beste option die brauche auf jeden fall ich habe es gehört das sagt
gerade mein video anguckt ich gucke mir das nachher an ich will ja kein doppel doppel react
machen so also das registrieren von kommando zeilen argumenten funktioniert wunderbar
mittlerweile und das angeben auf der kommando zeile funktioniert auch mittlerweile wunderbar
jetzt müssen wir gucken dass der kram aus environment variable config dateien auch
funktioniert das heißt wir gucken jetzt mal dass wir die anderen werte aus config datei
und environment variablen fahrt ihr herrlich 26 monat dankeschön für den sub das ist sehr
so wie kriegen wir die sache jetzt aus was wollen wir zuerst machen config datei oder
environment variable komm wir fangen mit environment variable an
jetzt muss ich mal was ausprobieren geht auch so was wie ein string array oder so
wahrscheinlich oder diese zuweisung ist auch so was wie einen string array kann ich das
so was wenn ich kackel und blub ich glaube ich muss mal meine option setzen das war hier
drinne ich glaube ich muss mal meine option setzen dass man mehrere davon angeben kann
das funktioniert jetzt nicht allow multiple per token genau
das ist zum string nice passt so sollte funktionieren mal first hat irgendjemand schon
eine clevere idee wie man das jetzt aus environment variablen auslesen könnte gescheit ok funktioniert
also man kann auch mit mit mit string arrays und mehreren argument das finde ich schon
mal sehr naht also wie könnte ich jetzt den kram nicht nur per kommando zeile sondern
auch per environment variablen rein bekommen also environment variablen muss irgendwie
prefixed sein als domain champ alles andere ist plötzlich nicht sonst beißt sich das
eventuell mit environment variablen die da sind so prefix domain champ danach quasi
name vom plugin und dann password password soll jetzt hier 1 2 3 4 5 6 einfach die n was
zu argumenten umwandeln ich glaube ich weiß was du meinst das ist absolut 6 hat idee chat
da wäre ich jetzt gar nicht drauf gekommen ich hätte jetzt das irgendwie selbst versucht
rauszupasen das ist mehr sehr feier ich glaube ich habe verstanden was er meint leute das
ist das ist 5 hat weintime man kann doch einfach das ist richtig gute idee das ist viel einfacher
als ich gedacht habe kommen wir können einfach easy kommen ok wie machen wir das jetzt am
besten tommy dankeschön für den zapp wir können einfach sagen environment get environment
variablen die environment variablen die heißt in dem fall dann die prefix name chat etwas
resize auf der anderen seite die heißt dann quasi domain champ weil es immer als prefix
hat sag du kannst auch configuration provider nehmen und dann den cli und nvr weiter ne das
funktioniert nicht ich weiß was du meinst du meinst das verstandermäßig drin ist das
funktioniert nicht weil bzw doch das funktioniert so ist es nicht prinzipiell funktioniert
das aber die möglichkeit optionen zu setzen also bei dem standard provider ist zum beispiel
cli arguments eklig weil es gar keine glaube ich gar keine automatische hilfe generiert
das nächste ist erase angeben ist zum beispiel absoluter abfuck du musst du musst mit dem
standard configurations provider müsstest du den ray anstatt so anzugeben glaube ich
so oder irgendwie irgendwie so angeben ganz ganz mir das war ich war ich lieber selbst
das kannst du keinem zumuten so optionen zu setzen und auch in der konfig datei ist eklig
ne das das hole ich mir lieber selbst hol ich mir lieber selbst raus da kann es dann lässt
sich das besser so bedienen wie ich mir das vorstelle also ist immer prefix mit domain
champ kann das übrigens nur zuweisen nur wenn das ok domain champ dann soll das gefolgt
werden von prefix und dann minus minus name also im prinzip wieder oben plus für die
environment variable entf gucken wir mal ob da was drinne steht entf nix drin achso weil
ich müsste angegeben habe da steht nix drin domain champ name ah nee habe ich was falsch
gemacht domain champ warum ist die environment variable nicht gesetzt achso vielleicht heißt
es gar nicht password moment moment vielleicht habe ich falsch geschrieben ist das groß und
klein schreibung relevant da ist es ok dann machen wir so und schreiben wir das alles
klein twitch chat ist eindeutig der bessere glitter copilot und schon älter vor allem
besser und älter ok das funktioniert so kriegt man das aus environment variable und wenn
ich das jetzt richtig verstanden habe was ich glaube der red dr geschrieben hat im chat
wir könnten jetzt einfach anstatt dass ich den kram hier selbst rauspase können nicht
einfach sagen wir adden die environment variable zu den argumenten das muss du doch eigentlich
funktionieren oder aber new list ja args gleich new list string argument so dann nehmen wir
die neuen und da hängen wir einfach jetzt die umgebungsvariable das geht nicht muss
das sind ray sein ok args add den name und args add das was immer in environment drin
steht oder ergibt das sinn jetzt bin ich mal gespannt ob ob ob ob ob ob ob ob ob ob ob ob
immer diese scheiße gar ok warum nicht ach so ah moment wo denn 31
ah weil nf nf kann das sein dass nf vielleicht leer ist ja ok nf muss ich checken if ob ob
ja ja ich muss gucken ob da was drin ist if string null or white space nf not null or
white space nf dann adden wir das liste kommt natürlich oben hin ob es jetzt funktioniert
aber wenn ich mache keine ausgabe funktioniert funktioniert jetzt passwort passwort übergebe
ich hier drüber was ob da jetzt der wert drinne steht ne fuck geht nicht das sollte
1 2 3 4 5 6 drinne stehen da steht null drinne warum warum steht da null drin sollte sollte
eigentlich wir gucken uns wir gucken uns mal kurz die args irgendwie join uns mal kurz
an was da drinne steht das steht drinne da sind ich glaube da fehlen die lehrzeichen
dazwischen kann das sein dass da die lehrzeichen fehlen run name cheap user kacke pass ach
moment moment moment moment da fehlt ja der prefix komplett das steht das steht passwort
das steht passwort gleich da müsste ja drinne stehen name cheap underscore underscore underscore
passwort also wir join das jetzt erst mal mit dem lehrzeichen dazwischen dann sieht
es vielleicht schon mal ein bisschen besser aus ok aber das ist natürlich verkehrt da
darf nicht name drinne stehen sondern options name muss da rein easy funktioniert alter
feifett idee der chat der chat wusste es wieder wir können einfach die environment variablen
anhängen und schon funktioniert ok das ist das ist easy das finde ich cool das hat was
ok das das war viel einfacher das war viel einfacher als gedacht vielleicht vielleicht
ist das ein bisschen fehler anfällig ich bin mir jetzt grad nicht sicher ob das ob
das funktioniert wir probieren das kann man noch mal anders join join am lehrzeichen
und dann machen wir das anders dann packen wir nämlich hier wir sagen hier args plus
gleich das darf ja eigentlich nur passieren wenn kein übergabeparameter übergeben wurde
korrekt du hast recht wir müssen returnen du hast recht wir müssen wir müssen hier
ein return machen wir müssen hier ein return machen wenn das wenn das erfolgreich war
ja ja ihr habt ihr habt recht chat so sieht aus so also machen wir hier argumente sagen
wir jetzt können wir eigentlich hier rein machen kommen wir da nicht temp temp args
neue args mit environment variablen dabei da sagen wir jetzt args plus gleich template
string lehrzeichen am anfang weil sonst bugs rum haben wir ja gelernt option punkt name
und dann sagen wir gleich machen wir die syntax da kann wahrscheinlich weniger kaputt gehen
gleich ent sollten wir da auch noch ein paar sachen es capen drin so und hier müssen wir
tatsächlich return machen also müssen wir checken option ist present args also wenn
es wenn es die option auf der kommando zeile gibt dann machen wir den return dann machen
wir return und return davon so args wenn es die nicht in der kommando zeile gibt dann
machen wir return davon und wenn moment add option machen wir immer und hier unten gibt
es default erst mal weil mir sonst nichts besseres einfällt so das müsste jetzt schon mal so
weit funktionieren genau wunderbar wunderbar wir können mal alles ausgeben wir lassen
mal die optionen die wir setzen ausgeben also string password geben aus user sollte auch
erkennen funktioniert also er erkennt dass wir user angegeben haben über kommando zeile
und er erkennt dass wir password über environment variablen gesetzt haben das ist schon mal
nice so jetzt fehlt bloß noch und das dürfte wahrscheinlich auch das komplizierteste werden
jetzt fehlt noch config file jetzt jetzt fehlt noch config file also wir wollen wir wollen
jetzt ja noch ein config file unterstützen also wir wollen quasi config jaml und config
jason unterstützen heißt im endeffekt haben wir mal sowas wie hier irgendwie falls die
wir ausprobieren view file info oder haben entweder config punkt jason oder wir haben
config punkt jaml oder config punkt jaml wunderbar haben wir das vielleicht ordentlich formatieren
lassen hat kein bock sich ordentlich zu format format ich will das eigentlich so haben aber
das war gar nicht vieles falls also wir wollen gucken wir wollen falls einlesen config jason
config jaml config jimmel das heißt wir gucken jetzt als erstes mal falls hörst ob es das
gibt das erste feil was es gibt interessiert uns das kann man bestimmt noch schöner machen
aber das ist das was mir so was mir so einfällt feil exist jetzt ist die frage wie handeln
wir dass es ein jason sein kann oder dass es ein jaml feil sein kann das eine muss man
ja mit dem jaml parser öffnen und das andere machen wir mit dem jason parser oder wir öffnen
beides mit dem jaml parser weil jason ist ja jaml nee doch nee nein also jedes gültige
jason dokument auch gültiges jaml dokument also wir könnten beides mit dem jaml parser
aber ich möchte die sachen eigentlich gar nicht mit dem jaml parser parsen weil der jaml parser ist
es sagt ich verwende lieber jason.net zum parsen heute ich habe ich habe eine idee und zwar ich
habe heute morgen ein example gefunden und zwar konvertiert der jaml jaml zu jason also was wir
machen könnten ist einfach immer die datei einlesen weil jedes gültige jason ein gültiges jaml wir
lesen die datei einfach immer mit dem jaml serializer ein und dann mit dem die mit dem
jaml die serializer und dann serialisieren wir es wieder als jason kompatibles jaml also wir
serialisieren jason wieder in jason und jaml wieder in jason und dann gehen wir mit jason.net
dran und lesen die sachen aus die wir brauchen excellent so machen wir das das dürfte wahrscheinlich
am einfachsten sein es wahrscheinlich auch nicht so nicht sonderlich schön aber es müsste
funktionieren also file serialize also wir wollen file read text text wie geht das open text read
to end wo ist jetzt schon wieder das problem wo ist das was das problem cannot resolve in
open text open text geht nach meinetwegen also wir lesen die dateien eigentlich also die erste
datei die wir finden lesen wir ein deserialisieren das jaml was da drin steht funktioniert auch für
jason weil jedes gültige jason gültiges jaml ist und dann serialisieren wir es wieder zu
jaml in jason kompatible ok das ist wirklich abartig aber das müsste funktionieren schauen
wir mal ausprobieren schauen wir mal gucken wir mal ok run ach das ist die config datei die wir
da schon liegen hatten ok das funktioniert wir machen man jaml wir machen man jaml feil wir machen
config config punkt hallo warum geht meine m tab completion nicht mehr config punkt jason also
wim config punkt jaml ok config punkt jaml so auf den temple darf man ja mittlerweile verzichten
wisst ihr das chat darf man mittlerweile auf minus minus minus am anfang der datei verzichten ich
glaube schon ich glaube das funktioniert also ich weiß dass es geht aber ich bin mir nicht sicher
ob es speck konform ist also legen wir mal was hier an zum beispiel ein name für den check und
da drinne dann teckel wunderbar das will ich haben und das soll ein int sein eins machen wir hier
789 ganz toller int das dürfte ein gültiges dürfte ein gültiges jaml sein hey funktioniert
es kommt ein jason objekt aus der jaml datei raus excellent soll was das sein und jetzt können
wir aus dem speck einfach ignorieren ja ist wahrscheinlich über vielen sachen und jetzt
können wir damit jason convert dran gehen und sagen wieder die serialize und das ganze jetzt
in ein jason container j container da kann man dann auf alles drauf zugreifen wie man will
ok das muss ich auf jeden fall hübscher machen auch das ist hochgradig abartig aber es müsste
funktionieren so und jetzt kann ich sagen ich möchte daraus extrahieren prefix und dann
nehmen was und ich sollte jetzt wenn alles funktioniert sollte ich 789 daraus bekommen
789 easy und schon kann man das ist ja so durch die prost ins auge man das ist ja so durch die
prost dass es überhaupt funktioniert und schon können wir kommando zeilen argumente
environment variablen und konfig dateien einlist das ist wirklich das ist wirklich sehr sehr wir
sehr sehr wir ok ich glaube ich glaube eine sache eine sache sollten wir noch machen ich glaube
wir sollten um das ganze den getreue catch block drumherum machen ich gehe davon aus das wird
wahrscheinlich das wird wahrscheinlich sofort crashen sobald es irgendwie falsch formatiert
probieren es doch mal aus mit konfig ja wir machen da mal irgendwie irgendwas irgendwas
doppelpunkt doppelpunkt das ist auf jeden fall jetzt falsch na gut ist aber auch logisch
spätestens spätestens hier muss das dann auch also sollten auf jeden fall noch ein
try catch drumherum machen oder oder wir sind tatsächlich noch ein bisschen ordentlicher
wir machen noch eine public class ab konfig feil oder sowas und wir hauen das wir hauen
das wir hauen das einfach da rein da können wir nämlich auch beispielsweise sagen string
name gleich konfig und man kann den name der konfig datei ändern da müssen wir plus das
so machen das nicht am ist und das das kommt weg können wir jetzt hier nämlich sagen lassen
dass sie auch in konstrukte ab konfig feil mit feil und dann hier auch ein new ab konfig
feil string name konfig alles ok so und jetzt kann ich jetzt könnte ich hier unten nämlich
sagen ab konfig nee das ist konfig konfig feil achso wie greife ich jetzt drauf zu
ok erste mal erste mal wenn wir dann einen try catch drumherum machen weil wir garantiert
irgendwelche laufen irgendwelche exceptions haben wenn es was nicht gibt wobei haben wir
da überhaupt irgendwelche exceptions die grunde haben wir da welche ja first spätestens
hier kackt ja schon ab spätestens spätestens hier wenn es das nicht gibt ich meine da müsste
man quasi sagen first or default und dann kann man wieder nicht open text wir machen
jetzt wir machen jetzt die die easy variante wir reppen das einfach mal und scheißen auf
die exception so wunderbar exzellent so und dieses jason das weisen wir irgendeinem
field zu jason container wunderbar dass es nicht null ist doch das macht unterschied
bei try catch muss ich nichts dran anpassen bei first or default müsste ich unten drunter
dann anpassen weil das hier dann da stimmt hast du eigentlich recht weil dann ist es
null na doch dann müsste ich ja wieder rum müsste ja wieder müsste ich ja wieder einen
try catch drumherum machen also ich mache einfach so einen try catch drum ja das reicht doch
eigentlich jetzt schon aber wir können wir können natürlich was richtig richtig advances
noch machen wie macht man indexer in seinen klassen das mache ich so selten wie sieht
man das aus die scharp class indexer keine ahnung using indexer ich habe keine ahnung
also was ein indexer ist es folgendermaßen ich kann jetzt konfig mit mit irgendwie hier
so per index quasi drauf zugreifen da weiß ich aber die syntax grad nicht hier public
int this und dann aha so ok so public load float null kein float objekt nee ich weiß
gar nicht was es ist ist auf jeden fall objekt als index set gibt es nicht jason was kommt
da raus was was returnt das sieht man das irgendwie
was was was was returnt das denn ein j token ok j token kann null sein so und jetzt kann
ich ja theoretisch an der stelle sagen warum ist die scharp cringe alle es ist alles cringe
wenn man nur lange lang genug danach sucht aber wenn mod da sind da sind macht die umfrage
er muss die er dafür immerhin seine kanalpunkte opfern mit denen wir nix sinnvolles anfangen
kann wenn keine mods da sind ich habe kein bock ins umbrauch zu erstellen mod mod check
also da machen wir jetzt hier richtig hart investiert also if ich überlege also wir
müssten jetzt ok also wir können schon mal sagen config file und dann müsste es hier
wieder sein prefix prefix und dann ein name null funktioniert jetzt ist natürlich das
problem wenn das wenn das null ist dann crash an der stelle das soll ja nicht crash ja wieso
passt kann ich das nicht einfach return an der stelle und gut ist so als letzte option
einfach sagen return ist da das wäre gut ist ja kein j objekt das muss ich schon karsten
irgendwie da muss ich jetzt sagen to objekt t oder oh nee das mag er nicht was hat er
für schmerzen an was an able to lift conditional access ach das ist wahrscheinlich weil das
null sein kann theoretisch und es nicht klar ist dass der typ überhaupt null supported
den man da rein steckt könnte ja auch den ins einen int kann er nicht null sein da funktioniert
das so schon mal nicht heißt im endeffekt hat sie hier ein fragezeichen das ist ja nur
optional in dort net immer also das heißt ich müsste jetzt quasi gucken ok ich müsste
hier schauen das da ist not null und dann kann ich und dann kann ich moment moment moment
das fragezeichen weg dann wirft seine exception wenn wenn ich da drauf zugreife wenn ich das
weg machen dann wirft seine exception wenn ich auf was zugreife was ich da ist das will
ich ja nicht einfach dahinter nee das geht nicht der hat sich der stört sich ja schon
an der stelle dass da null rauskommen kann weil ich sage hier to objekt t und ich müsste
ich müsste wahrscheinlich sowas wie lullabee t machen wird das funktionieren nee das mag
er nicht weil das weil es auch nicht nur sein kann ach keine ahnung wir können es aber
so machen ist not ist j token tmp und dann kann ich sagen nur die turn so das funktioniert
das funktioniert ok was hat er für einen vorschlag use null check pattern where t class
nee das funktioniert nicht meine options können ins ins sein zum beispiel was ist das also
möchten die mir bei microsoft irgendwie wirklich erzählen das das ist moment dass das so schöner
ist als so seriously er meinetwegen also was findet ihr schöner chat also ich finde ja
wenn er j token steht das deutlich lesbare als wenn da sowas steht so eklig was ist denn
config file config file ist entweder config punkt json config punkt jammel oder config
punkt jimmel das kann das kann eines von dreien sein
ich hätte vorschlag ja i convertible inwieweit hat es jetzt damit was zu tun also ich meine
man könnte hier convert und dann auch jetzt nichts großartiges oder das
wieweit hat es jetzt mit meinem problem zu tun dass das basis datentypen
sind habt ihr eigentlich schon nee erzähl mal ich verstehe ich verstehe nicht was du
meinst habt ihr eigentlich schon das dort netmel mal video aufgenommen aber nicht aber
wahrscheinlich dann das wochenende so so müsste das jetzt doch funktionieren könnte übrigens
an der stelle sogar das ist ok kann man das weglassen ok ach so wer t i convertible das
ist eine coole idee da wäre jetzt gar nicht drauf gekommen ich hoffe ich hoffe dass options
die gleiche einschränkung hat ach tatsächlich anscheinend was was haben die für constraints
hier i value descriptor sind arrays convertible sind arrays convertible nee oder dann wird
schon wieder nicht funktionieren wenn ich hier zum beispiel jetzt sage get int array
dann geht es nicht weil es nicht convertible ist ok nope können wir nicht machen ansonsten
war aber eine gute idee du bist erst gerade reingekommen ja dann was für domains willst
du wie monitor mit deinem tool kann ich erzählen und zwar ich will das ablaufdatum meiner domains
monitor und ich habe domains bei fünf verschiedenen anbietern und es gibt nichts was das gescheit
überwacht es gibt ein paar tools die über who is gehen aber who is hinkt mir bei den
meisten domains nicht weil da kein expired date drinne steht es gibt irgendein php tool
was das macht aber auch nicht in einem gescheiten format exportiert und auch nicht alle anbieter
unterstützt die ich haben will und ich möchte beispielsweise das easy ins prometheuse oder
easy ins topics einbinden können was im endeffekt heißt es muss ein prometheuse exporter sein
ist das mit dem wer bei link was ist das bei dem wer was ist das mit dem wer bei der signatur
so ein link ding wahrscheinlich ich sehe es zwar gerade nicht aber wo denn ach hier oben
das ne ne ne ne das hat mit link nichts zu tun dass hier oben ist wenn du sagst wer ti
ist i convertible das bedeutet dass du nur typen hier also das bedeutet dass du das hier
nur mit typen aufrufen kannst die davon abgeleitet sind die das interface implementieren du kannst
zum beispiel auch sagen t-class dann kannst du nur klassen und keine value types also
da könntest du hier nur klassen und beispielsweise kein int und so was reinstecken das ist eine
quasi für ein filter für deinen typ was du denn da rein stecken kannst das ist
das ist leute ich muss sagen das ist ausgesprochen lesbar damit hätte ich jetzt nicht gerechnet
guck mal ich meine das ist doch wirklich übersichtlich da erkennt auch jeder was passiert erst machen
wir erst machen wir kommando zeile dann machen wir entweilen mit variabel und dann machen
wir config fall das soll eigentlich total easy und das das schlimme ist ja noch das
funktioniert ja doch ist nicht eben hat es doch noch funktioniert was habe ich was habe
ich jetzt kaputt gemacht habe ich irgendwas geändert noch wir können das so umschreiben
so machen ja das kann man tatsächlich machen habe ich irgendwas jetzt geändert dass es
nicht mehr funktioniert command line debugging beste er findet doch was warum
ich bin ja auch doof guck mal ich gebe was aus was es gar nicht gibt ja dann ist kein
wundern dass es funktioniert ok das finde ich war richtig nice so gefällt mir das guck
mal wir haben jetzt die möglichkeit plugins zu registrieren die plugins können sich können
parameter die plugins können parameter registrieren die dann auch in der hilfe auftauchen guck
nameshieb user password und keckel weil wir unbedingt keckel angeben müssen als option
und die optionen können aus environment variable kommando zeile und config fall kommen es ist
und das und auf unterschiedlichste art und das ist mega nice das gefällt mir wirklich
gut hätte ich gar nicht gedacht dass es so einfach funktioniert und password ist auch
ein string und es ist ja im prinzip kein password das ist ein api tauchen tauchen
ja muss man jetzt darf kann immer mal null sein muss man dann später checken so tauchen
und das ist user das ist doch wirklich eine ganz coole sache also das ist auch eine api
die checkt im endeffekt jeder du du wird es wird einmal register aufgerufen in register
kannst du deine kannst du quasi deine optionen definieren die du haben willst für kommando
zeile und environment alles mögliche und du kannst dir gleich den wert wert holen mehr
brauchst du doch eigentlich das auch vollkommen ok so als kann man noch in it reinschreiben jetzt
kann man noch in it reinschreiben so den test zum beispiel könnte man es machen jetzt könnte
man in it checken ist dann auch das ganze also ist das ist das das gültige sind die optionen
gültig muss man ja auch noch überprüfen weil es könnte ja sein dass irgendeine option übergibt
die gar nicht gültig sind also zum beispiel dass im username sonderzeichen in vorkommen
obwohl es da anbieter nicht unterstützt oder sowas kann ja alles sein am ende muss das muss
das ganze ausgeführt werden also dass mit in it ersparen wir uns jetzt erstmal da muss
ich mir irgendwas gescheites überlegen mit return weiter zu dass mit dem run probiere ich
noch mal schnell aus dass wir so bevor wir bevor wir das nächste mal weitermachen dass wir so die
grobe struktur von von diesem tool haben so also run cmd set handler context da kann man dann
haben wir den überhaupt ja für für cancellation brauchen wir das cancellation token warum ein
nullable string weil weil es ja durchaus sein kann dass es die option gar nicht gibt also es
ist ja möglich dass irgendjemand die option nicht angibt also mal angenommen jemand gibt nur user
an jemand gibt nur user an und kein token oder gibt nur talk an und kein user dann ist ja das
was hier zurückkommt null das ist zwar ein fehler aber an der stelle können wir noch keinen fehler
werfen den fehler können wir erst hier werfen jetzt hier müssen wir das erstmal so hinnehmen
dass das so ist also das kann ja durchaus sein dass einer einfach nur misst angibt zb wenn
einer gar nichts angibt ist beides null das ist halt zu dem zeitpunkt noch so jetzt jetzt für
wir den krempel mal aus also run so wir haben eigentlich alles angegeben was wir brauchen wir
haben passwort über environment und user über kommando zeilen parameter angegeben jetzt für
wir den ganzen jetzt für den ganzen krempel mal aus also wie kann man das wie kann man das am
besten machen wir müssen das ja multis werden ausführen quasi alle alle plugins nebeneinander
das heißt im endeffekt brauchen wir erst mal unsere ganzen checks also mal checks vor
check jeder check so der hat der run run in it und register register und in it ist
schon gelaufen hier sind wir bei run so wir wollen jetzt allerdings einen run einmalig machen über
alle sondern wir wollen alles ausführen parallel heißt wie machen wir das jetzt am besten ja und
nicht nur einmalig ausführen sondern im hintergrund immer weiter ausführen
oder was heißt im hintergrund muss ich im hintergrund sein aber immer immer weiter
ausführen wollen wir das also brauchen wir eigentlich eher so eine art weilschleife oder
ein timer aber der timer moment der intervall kann ja unterschiedlich sein wo check das heißt wir
müssen tatsächlich jeden check in einem eigenen spread starten und da drinne dann die weilschleife
machen ok also task run ob haben wir nix ja das ist ja das ist ja quasi so was wie go fun hier
das ist von heute mal noch einmal großartig großartig länger so und da drinne quasi
in den wild true da drinne machen warte task die lei check intervall so es muss
sein den return wert davon interessiert mich nicht spuky spuky musik passt passt hier gut
dazu ins wild true es ist übrigens nicht weil tru es ist weil cancellation top ist not
cancellation requested ja der chat hat es auch gemerkt wieder richtig high IQ von allem oder
in dem fall vom seto super high IQ wieder dass er es gesehen hat so und jetzt müssen wir da drin
sagen a weight oder gibt das check run war result gleich a weight check run
cancellation talking tru 0w so dann sind wir mal vorsichtig vielleicht gibt es ja eine exception
drin die werden wir einfach mal ignorieren man weiß ja nie was in dieser run method also plugins
kannst du nicht trauen mit dem result machen wir jetzt irgendwas das muss jetzt bin ich mal
gespannt ob das funktioniert result in dem result sollte jetzt ja domain expires was auch
immer rauskommen schauen wir mal warum ich bin ja doof ich werfe die tasks ja weg ich werfe die
tasks ja weg ich will ja das ist das ist das ist plötzlich nicht so ich muss warten ich muss warten
am ende dass alle tasks dass alle tasks beendet sind also müsste ich die theoretisch erwarten ok
das könnte das jetzt jetzt ok was wir fallen als zwei sachen ein was wir machen können also so
funktioniert es schon mal nicht weil an der stelle genau das würde funktionieren da muss
ich aber erstmal in den task array rauskriegen das würde funktionieren dann läuft aber immer
nur einer gleichzeitig das ist das ist doof richtig genau daran habe ich auch gerade gedacht wir
machen parallel parallel for each async und da muss ich einmal gucken ob das auch wirklich
funktioniert so wie ich mir das vorstelle so checks eigentlich brauchen wir den name nicht
aber bei komm checks und dann async check key value pair und ohne das jetzt jetzt ist jetzt
so und jetzt kommt das da rein funktioniert das jetzt warum nicht weil es kein check gibt
die construct name check dann einfach mal ein weil nicht mit kopiert ok ob das jetzt funktioniert
alles beendet sich schon ach so moment das ergibt keinen sinn das ob er doch oder so oder nicht ja
aber so komm mal alle fünf sekunden wird da aus es passt oder also oder mal gucken aber alle
habe ich überhaupt alle fünf sekunden eingestellt ja alle ok jetzt stelle ich mal alle ein seek alle
eines oh das abbrechen ist noch ein bisschen verbackt warum ist das abbrechen verbackt
weil ich hier nicht auf das weil weil ich hier nicht auf das cancellation talk warte
was ist das ziel bei dem projekt dass du das ablauf datum von deinen domains in ein monitoring
ordentlich rein kriegst über die api der jeweiligen domain registrat und sowas gibt es
aus irgendwelchen gründen ich habe keine ahnung warum sollte das funktioniert beim easy im
sekundenintervall wird jetzt gecheckt ergibt das sinn was ich hier gemacht habe so wir gucken jetzt
mal ob die alle gleichzeitig laufen du hast recht wir gucken mal ob die alle gleichzeitig laufen
das können wir ja nur das können wir nur ausprobieren indem wir einfach mal mehrere
starten also sagen wir sowas hier running und dann plus nehmen ja gut genug tritt wenn ich
genug tritts verfügbar sind im pool ist ja auch ok dass er langsamer macht aber ich glaube was
ist standardmäßig der thread pool kernanzahl mal zwei oder sowas oder ich glaube sogar noch
mehr tausend 24 oder so was mittlerweile oder sogar noch mehr ist es reicht auf jeden fall
aber du hast schon recht wenn wir es von hand starten würden wir vielleicht besser
vor Shu tempted
so war das so Thrones
Da muss das.
Ich dachte, Andersgold ist Discard und kein Name.
So, jetzt probieren wir das mal aus.
Also, ich meine, hier innen, diese Dinger werden natürlich ausgeführt,
indem wir überlegen, Checkintervall.
Jetzt brauche ich mal ein zweites, jetzt brauche ich mal ein zweites Plugin.
Das kriegt die gleichen Sachen wie das, heißt jetzt aber nicht Namecheap,
sondern heißt Tacklechamp, Check.
Also immer. Mal gucken, ob die jetzt parallel laufen.
Sieht ziemlich parallel aus, oder?
Na gut, die Dinger sind so schnell, die Dinger sind so schnell.
Machen wir mal was. Machen wir mal was anderes.
Red ist jetzt übrigens Absicht, dass ich nicht erwarte,
sondern wirklich so tue als Dauerslänger. Sleep. Fünf Sekunden.
Aber hier davor. Red Sleep. Fünf Sekunden.
Und.
Nein, nein, nein, ich sage doch, das ist nicht Task Delay.
Task Delay will ich nicht an der Stelle.
Ich will wirklich, das soll hart blockieren, also sehe ich das ja nicht.
So flieht es, sage ich noch nichts. Ja, es funktioniert.
Ja, es läuft parallel.
Okay, es läuft parallel. Alles klar.
Komm, jetzt muss ich natürlich fünf Sekunden warten mit Cancel,
weil deswegen sollte man übrigens Threads Sleep
auch nur benutzen, wenn es nicht anders geht. Nice.
Okay, das funktioniert. Das ist jetzt wirklich. Das ist eine coole Sache.
Das gefällt mir.
Also wir haben quasi so die Basic Struktur von diesem Programm soweit.
Jetzt fehlt noch ein Prometheus Exporter.
Den machen wir schnell rein.
Ich meine, wie gesagt, das ist noch sehr roh alles
und hat ja auch noch keine richtige Funktionalität,
dass es wirklich zu einem Domain Registrar geht.
Und das checkt Amazon von der von der Basic Struktur.
Funktionierte schon mal alles.
So, jetzt brauchen wir noch einen Prometheus Exporter.
Da tue ich mir immer schwer mit.
Ich vergesse immer, wie man diese komische Library verwendet.
Vor allem, wenn man Labels braucht und so was ist das wirklich abpackt.
Okay, also wir müssen einen Prometheus Server starten.
Also für Metrik, Metrik.
Export, Point, Endpoint, Web Server Endpunkt, API Endpunkt.
Machen wir natürlich, bevor wir unser komisches Parallel
for each laufen haben.
Für Centiu.
Also da brauchen wir so was hier, wenn ich das jetzt richtig sehe,
hier gerade auf dem zweiten Bildschirm. Metrix.
Erst mal Suppress Default, Metrix, Metrix Server.
Wie ging das? Prometheus, Prometheus.
Ich gucke gerade ab, das weiß ich aus dem Kopf nicht. Metrix Server.
Dann sagt man den Port, also irgendwie 9.9.0.0 oder so was.
9.010.910 ist glaube ich Prometheus Default Server. Hab ich das falsch gemacht?
Weil Classname ist not valid.
Ach so, ja, wer ist da mit New da vor, da wird das noch funktionieren.
So und jetzt Server starten.
Das ist doch wie Wait oder so, ne, da macht einfach weiter im Background.
Und nun sollte das doch eigentlich funktionieren.
Wir können jetzt noch so was, wir können jetzt noch so was
angehen wie eine Konsole. Ups, dann so was habe ich CW.
Ist Parallel for Each und Task Run nicht doppelt parallel?
Ne. Ach so, warte mal.
Ja, es hat für mich, es hat für mich eben Sinn ergeben, als ich das gebaut habe.
Ich würde sagen, das hat seinen Sinn.
Ich bin mir jetzt selbst gerade gar nicht mehr so sicher.
Ne, natürlich, natürlich, ich will ja, dass alles in seinem eigenen Thread läuft.
Ja, doch, doch, das ist.
Vielleicht mache ich das auch noch mal anders.
So wirklich, wirklich klar strukturiert ist das hier nicht, was da passiert.
Aber es funktioniert erst mal.
So, vielleicht sollten wir jetzt noch eine Konsolenausgabe machen.
So nach dem Motto auf Http doppelt Punkt doppelt.
Local Host Port 9010 Slash Matrix läuft dieses Ding. Ups, noch mal.
Matrix Open Link.
OK. Ich habe Start vergessen, ich Kack Noob, Alter.
Server Start. Mensch, Lull.
Alles klar.
Funktioniert. Wir haben da noch keine Daten drinstehen,
deswegen ist da nichts, aber es funktioniert.
OK, dann müssen wir jetzt noch mal ein bisschen Prometheus Zeug exportieren.
Und es heißt diese Library, ich kann ich muss abgucken,
ich kann diesen Kram nicht richtig, richtig bedienen.
Die ist auch irgendwie ein bisschen, ein bisschen eklig.
Man muss mal sowas, aber ich kopiere es mir einfach.
Na ja, komm, alles gleich.
Matrix Create Gorge.
Haben wir letztens gehört, wie man das ausspricht?
Gauge Gorge Domain.
Also das ist, das ist dann, wie das die exportierte Metrik heißt.
Dann brauchen wir den Hilfetext.
Hilfe braucht man nicht.
Hilfe ist für Nupes, Omega Null.
Und als Label braucht man dann sowas wie Target,
das ist dann quasi für jede Domain extra kopiert.
Mal gucken, was passiert, wenn ich jetzt ausführe,
ob da schon was drinsteht.
Aha, steht schon mal drin, ohne dass Werte drinstehen.
Was genau Prometheus ist das einfach ein klein für Statistik
Virtualisierung.
Das ist ein Server mit Metriken, den du von Prometheus einsammeln kannst.
Also das hier ist ein Prometheus Exporter.
Prometheus ist der Server, der dann die Exporter einsammelt.
Prometheus ist quasi eine Datenbank für Metriken.
Und an Prometheus selbst kannst du dann wiederum
beispielsweise ein Grafana oben draufsetzen.
Prometheus selbst hat zwar ein Webinterface,
aber ist nicht so schön zum Anzeigen.
Prometheus selbst lässt du dann wieder Grafana draufzugreifen
und visualisierst damit deine Metrikdaten.
Mittlerweile muss man aber sagen,
dieses Prometheus Node Exporter Format ist relativ beliebt.
Du kannst Node Exporter mittlerweile nicht nur in Prometheus verwenden,
obwohl es Prometheus Exporter sind.
Du kannst in Zappix Prometheus Exporter einbinden.
Du kannst in CheckMK Prometheus Exporter einbinden.
Also Prometheus Exporter hat sich so ein bisschen etabliert,
als für Monitoring Daten bereit zu stellen.
Ist Prometheus also eine Art Proxy für Daten Monitoring?
Ja, man kann das mit ganz viel Fantasie vielleicht so umschreiben.
Prometheus selbst ist eine Time-Series-Datenbank mit einem
zusätzlichen Crawler, der Metriken einsammeln kann.
Es ist eigentlich eine Datenbank.
Es ist eine Time-Series-Datenbank mit einem Crawler,
der Metriken einsammeln kann.
Und darauf kannst du dann mit Grafana oder mit was du willst
eigentlich zugreifen.
Muss ja nicht Grafana sein.
Grafana bietet sich in dem Fall halt an.
Was mache ich da eigentlich gerade?
Okay, jetzt setzen wir mal was.
Hier ist das Result.
Also, sagen wir mal Labels.
Ich gucke das ab.
Ich gucke das hier in der ReadMe ab.
Ich habe keine Ahnung, wie das funktioniert.
Ich kann diese Library immer nicht bedienen,
wenn ich sie bedienen muss.
Also ich sage mal hier Result.
Die Domain, das ist wie es heißt, also wie das gelabelt wird.
Dann können wir sagen Set.
So, und Set, da kommt jetzt die Zeit rein,
wann das Ganze expired.
Also expires add.
Da habe ich jetzt mein eigenes, aktuelles Datum immer eingetragen,
aber dann sieht man nichts, was passiert.
So, expires add.
Wie kriegt man to?
Offset?
Nee, oh fuck, wie funktioniert das nochmal?
Date, time, offset.
Date, time, ist es fast, das ist in.NET fast so schlimm
wie in JavaScript mit Date, time.
Unix time, milliseconds.
Okay, das klingt gut.
Okay, wunderbar.
Ausführen.
Zack, Domain, wo bloß Punkt TV läuft ab in.
Man sieht so alle einmal in der Sekunde aktualisiert das.
Ich refleche jetzt schneller.
Funktioniert.
Also die grobe Struktur von unserem Exporter tut.
Domain, wo bloß Punkt TV, was übrigens nicht stimmt,
dass die jetzt abläuft.
Hast du das Result drinne?
So, und das Coole ist, sobald ich mehrere Domains drinne.
Moment, Moment, einen Fehler sehe ich noch.
Einen Fehler sehe ich an der Stelle noch.
Domaincheck Result sollte ein Array sein.
Das ist sinnvoll.
Oder um genau zu sein, könnte es auch kein Array sein,
sondern ein innumerable Result, weil ich habe ja mehrere.
Weil ich habe ja mehrere Domaincheck Results,
weil ich mehrere Domains habe, nicht zwangsläufig eins.
Also müsste man dann quasi so was hier machen.
So, und jetzt sieht man auch gleich,
sobald es eine weitere Domain gibt, in dem Fall keine Ahnung wo bloß
Punkt dE.
Ich starte mal kurz neu.
Normalerweise musst du nicht neu steuern, weil es web.
Jetzt klappt es natürlich mit dem Result nicht mehr.
Logisch, logisch, logisch.
Geht das Result natürlich nicht mehr.
Muss ich sagen, vor each.
Domains nennen oder sowas.
Was schlägt er mir dann vor?
Domaincheck Result.
Check Result, Check Result, starten wir mal neu.
Und zack, haben wir beide Domains drin.
Und wenn ich jetzt, das können wir jetzt nicht ausprobieren,
das können wir erst das nächste Mal ausprobieren,
wenn wir das dann wirklich auch mal über eine API,
über einen Webservice connecten.
Wenn ich jetzt eine weitere Domain registriere und das ist wirklich eines der coolen Sachen
da dran.
Beangenehm, ich gehe jetzt zu meinem Domain Registral,
registriere mir jetzt eine weitere Domain.
Die wird ohne, dass ich irgendwas machen muss,
automatisch mit ins Monitoring aufgenommen.
Beangenehm, ich gehe jetzt zu meinem Domain Registral,
registriere mir wo bloß Punkt blub.
Würd mich nicht wundern, wenn es Punkt blub als Top Level Domain mittlerweile gibt.
Schon steht das drin und ist im Monitor.
Das ist nice.
Was ist denn das 167, das ist Unix Timestamp in Millisekunden,
wann die Domain abläuft.
Was natürlich Blödsinn ist, das ist die aktuelle Zeit.
Das ist die aktuelle Zeit, aber es ist ein Unix Timestamp in Millisekunden.
Sehr nice, das finde ich wirklich gut.
Das ging einfacher, als ich mir das vorgestellt habe.
Nice, das gefällt mir richtig gut, Leute.
Jetzt haben wir es von der Struktur, haben wir es ungefähr so, wie es sein soll.
Wir können doch mal eine Sache testen, wenn noch was passiert,
was passiert, wenn der Exception auftritt.
Wollen wir hier Throw, New, also Exception ist in dem Fall,
wenn jemand das falsche Emote verwendet, weil wir hier alle wissen,
dass Lul B gleich Keg B ist.
Mal gucken, was passiert, wenn der Exception auftritt.
Ja, nichts, es läuft einfach weiter.
Es wird einfach wieder gestartet, aber es aktualisiert nicht logischerweise,
weil es ja dabei abkackt.
Da sollten wir vielleicht noch was loggen, vielleicht soll ich das nächste Mal
auch eine ordentliche Logging Library.
Jetzt werden wir sehen, jedes Mal gibt es eine Exception,
dementsprechend, aber es kackt, das Programm kackt nicht ab,
das ist ja das Wichtige daran.
Also sprich, wenn irgendein Plugin, oder sagen wir mal,
mein Internet ist down und es gibt keine Verbindung zum Checken,
dann soll der das Programm nicht abkacken.
Ja, so ist das eigentlich ganz nice.
Wisst ihr, was mir zum Testen in.NET, was ich mir schon öfters mal
gewünscht hätte, was man relativ einfach selbst bauen kann?
Ja, ich hätte gerne sowas.
Äh, keine Ahnung. Wisst ihr, was ich, was ich, was ich weine?
Sowas, sowas, wobei, das ist eigentlich falsch rum.
Sowas, sowas in der Richtung hätte ich eigentlich gerne.
Null Exception, weil manchmal will man was ausprobieren
und hätte gerne random, und hätte, hätte gerne random,
man kann ja Extensions bauen, ja, ich weiß, das ist easy,
aber ich fände es cool, wenn sowas dabei wäre,
weil man dann eigentlich eher sowas machen müsste.
Sowas, ich meine, wir können das mal machen.
Ich kann euch zeigen, wie einfach man im Prinzip sowas erweitern kann,
weil wir es da auch, ups, weil wir es da auch gestern von hatten,
dass sowas in C++ auch ganz cool wäre.
Also, sowas gibt es ja nicht. Throw random hat, hat, hat das nicht.
So, bam, kaputt. Und ich kann jetzt beispielsweise mal hier
mein Helper, Helper-File gehen und dann sagen wir,
okay, wir wollen eine weitere Extension-Message machen,
und zwar in dem Fall für Exception.
Wie heißt Throw Random?
Oh, jetzt sehen wir schon, okay, jetzt verschwindet der,
ja, ja, freut, jetzt sehen wir schon, jetzt verschwindet der Fehler,
der ganze Kram lässt sich wieder kompilieren, machen,
machen tut es natürlich nichts. So, und jetzt könnte ich zum
Beispiel sagen random Punkt, Shared Punkt,
das ist immer ganz praktisch, wenn man globales Random verwenden will
und nicht in das Problem laufen will, dass man mit dem gleichen
Seed zweimal aufruft, so, zur gleichen Zeit,
dass das random Shared, so, jetzt können wir zum Beispiel sagen
Next von 0 bis 0 bis 100 oder 1% oder so, man könnte hier hinten
noch dann die Wahrscheinlichkeit oder so was hinschreiben.
Also, so, wenn das hier jetzt größer als 8 ist, sagen wir mal,
dann soll er das bauen. Und jetzt sollte ab und zu mal eine
Exception fliegen, wisst ihr, habt ihr gesehen,
Bäm, ab und zu gibt es jetzt eine Exception.
A Next Boole ist blöd, wenn man irgendwie so 70% oder so 80%,
wobei das auch nicht 80% sind, da müsste ich glaube ich von 1 bis 11 machen,
größer gleich, größer gleich, größer gleich in 1 bis 11,
aber ihr seht ab und zu so in ungefähr 20% der Fälle,
übrigens auch eine super Sache, um seinen Arbeitsplatz zu sichern
oder zu zerstören, je nachdem, je nachdem, wie man es verkauft.
Du bist der Einzige, der es fixen kann.
Ja, coole Sache, nice. Freut mich, dass das so gut
funktioniert hat. Das heißt eigentlich, wir haben,
wie oft sage ich eigentlich noch, das heißt, ich sage klar,
das heißt, das heißt, das heißt, aber das heißt,
dass wir das nächste Mal uns wirklich ums Implementieren kümmern können.
Vielleicht gucke ich mir den ganzen Spaß hier mit.
Dependency Injection und Hosted Services dafür noch mal an.
Vielleicht braucht man das ja gar nicht so,
sondern kann ein paar Sachen wiederverwenden,
die die schon ins Framework eingebaut haben.
Wobei ich aber sagen muss, nein, das sind 87 Zeilen,
braucht man dafür wirklich noch Dependency Injection und alles obendrauf?
Ich weiß nicht.
Ob das wirklich notwendig ist? Ich glaube, ich lasse das so.
Okay, Leute, das war es für heute.
Nächstes Mal, wenn wir was Funktionsfähiges haben,
kommt es dann auch auf GitHub. Wir sehen uns im nächsten Stream.
Ich gehe jetzt was essen. Ich habe mega Hunger.
Hyper P-Pro-Fat, Leute. Wir sehen uns im nächsten Stream.
Ich hoffe, euch hat es gefallen. Macht es gut.
Bis denn. Noch die Reaktion.
Das gucke ich mir irgendwann ohne. Okay, erinnert mich dran, Leute.
Erinnert mich dran. Im nächsten Stream merkt es euch.
Ich werde wahrscheinlich nicht dran denken.
Merkt es euch und erinnert mich dran.
Wir gucken uns, wir reacten das nächste Mal auf die Reaktion.
Und dann machen wir den C-Sharp-Test.
Den habe ich auch noch nicht gemacht, den jemand geschickt hat.
Alles klar, wir sehen uns. Bis denn. Macht es gut.
Bis morgen.